the esteemed Dr Thomas morstead entered
the cell of the anomaly if he'd been
warned and even chastised by his
colleagues
but who in the foundation could tell him
what to do
he was the best at what he did
maybe the greatest in the whole history
of the foundation
as he entered the room
scp-049 bid in welcome cordial as always
so polite in fact that you'd never guess
you were talking to a killer Dr morstead
knew the truth of what he was dealing
with
but he also believed he could get
through to zero four nine calm him
exercise the devil from him it was the
meeting of two great minds one of them
human one of them part human part
something that has never been clear it
was to be a battle of wits and like so
many great battles this one would turn
into a massacre before we get to that
fateful meeting there are some things
you should know about the anomaly known
as
scp-049 if you saw him in the street the
first thing you'd think of is playing
because 049 always looked the same a man
dressed in black robes with a plague
doctor's mask but this wasn't a costume
that could be taken off in fact it
wasn't a costume at all
was and the robes had grown out of him
like an exoskeleton that horrible mask
with the pointed nose wasn't covering
his face it was his face a kind of shell
that had seemingly sprouted from bone
the first reports came during World War
II in a picturesque town in the south of
France called montavon people had begun
going missing children disappeared from
their beds in the middle of the night
and weren't seen again adults went to
the market and never returned local
authorities searched high and low they
scoured nearby woods and dragged the
rivers but nothing was found because
what was happening wasn't Criminal there
was no clue they could stumble upon or
eyewitness who would break the case now
this was something else something that
the townsfolk could never understand
word spread and that's when a search and
Discovery team was sent from the
foundation it was a cold Dark Night in
January of 1941 when the team found what
they were looking for they walked
through the open door of a small house
located not too far from the Grand
Chateau de Lucia to find a masked man
sitting next to an open fire and he
wasn't alone the floor around him looked
like it was moving upon closer
inspection the team saw that the floor
was covered with writhing grasping
bodies its patience as it called them
bienvenues said nothing welcome to my
home those so-called patients crawled
towards the team intended scene to cause
harm the hostiles now known as
scp-049-2s were deemed dangerous and had
to be eliminated a sight it seemed that
didn't bother 049 in the slightest it
just sat there occasionally looking up
from writing notes in 11 the round book
as his patience were gunned down once
the Carnage ended it simply closed its
book stood up and allowed itself to be
escorted away and that's the story of
how 049 ended up at the facility
becoming a guest of sorts staying in a
standard secure humanoid containment
cell research sector 0-2 site 19. the
few that came into contact with 049
remarks that it was a pleasure for them
with its impeccable manners vast
knowledge of medicine and human anatomy
sharp tongue and stinging wet they
almost became Spellbound listening to it
caught in the throes of its charms until
with the Simple Touch of its hand it
would drain the light from them that's
why scp-049 was classified as a Euclid
that's why armed guards were always
stationed outside itself it's why
doctors took great precautions when in
its presence and it's why Dr morstead
should have known better remember when
049 was discovered in France it
willingly went with the team like it was
happy it had been found as if it had
planned its own
when it arrived at the facility it
didn't act like it was contained against
its well it was like it was returning
home initial findings as to the biology
of 049 were that it didn't require any
sustenance at all not even water it
seemed content to be left alone with its
notebooks it did not object when it was
asked if it could share some of its
notes and gladly handed over its
journals but upon examination it was
discovered that they were written in the
language that no linguist or
cryptologist has so far been able to
translate it's apparent that 049 derives
much satisfaction from seeing so-called
experts struggle over its text unable to
read those notes a long line of doctors
visited 0-49 in itself each fascinated
by what they beheld it was learned that
it has traveled the globe it speaks many
languages but prefers to speak what it
calls
French it asked for only one thing
warm-blooded animals the facility agreed
to supply 049 with various kinds
including rabbits cattle and even an ape
on one occasion just like with humans it
could kill the animals with a mere Touch
of its hand sucking the life right out
of them but that wasn't even the most
incredible part soon those animals would
rise again as if reanimated by 0-49 they
would become for all intents and
purposes the Living Dead and they were
hostile after several unfortunate
incidents they were taken from the cell
the moment they arose and disposed of in
the incinerator this was not to the
liking of 049 who would claim it had
cured the animals for it the world was
sick it saw plague and pestilence
everywhere and the meaning of its
existence was to rid the world of
disease humans it said contained a virus
and had to be cleansed in the first days
after arriving at the facility 049
didn't seem to pose a threat to humans
it was quite friendly in fact the seemed
aware of the fear it caused in staff and
would often go out of its way to make
them feel comfortable and safe this was
a ruse of course or a Canard a zero four
nine like to say it had no intention to
help humans no it had come for humans it
wasn't trapped it it had set a trap one
of the first people to truly upset 049
was Dr Raymond Hamm a well-respected
physician that had twice been a
contender for the Nobel Prize for his
more mainstream work what had confused
Dr Ham the most was not zero four nines
clothes like exoskeleton or even his
ability to reanimate the dead but the
bag that it used 049 was somehow able to
pull a seemingly endless supply of
surgical tools from that bag sometimes
it would even pull out objects that Were
Somehow larger than the bag itself it
was as if the bag connected to somewhere
else and that's what Dr Ham wanted to
talk about on that fateful day with 049
on one side of the cell and Dr Ham on
the other he asked how is it that you
can produce a great quantity of tools
from that bag I've observed you and it
seems to me that you are doing The
Impossible dear doctor
replied049 The Scourge The Great dying
cannot be fought with a handful of toys
my bag is merely the product of my
imagination it gives me what I require
you dear sir it seems are limited by
your imagination it stopped for a second
or two and stared at Dr Ham I detect you
are unwell it's sad and a voice not as
amiable as before it's just a cold said
the doctor ah just a cold if you had
seen what I have seen you would not
utter such insulting words Dr Ham pulled
out some papers from a briefcase and
approached 049 holding them close enough
so it could read them you see said Dr
Ham pointing to the results on the paper
those animals you say you cured they
were not diseased they were perfectly
healthy before they died and your
so-called cure it turned them into
something quite terrible we found that
if they were left alone they began to
eat each other and then the themselves
049 did not respond after a brief pause
said only a good day to your doctor
please close the door on your way out
you should get some rest
ham refused to go and instead turned the
conversation to this real interest the
bag demanding that 049 let him see
inside of it very well doctor zero four
nine seven in private 049 began to pull
a series of long metal poles out of its
bag followed by a rolled up curtain that
it hung between them creating a kind of
medical tent around Dr Ham it seemed to
stare for just a moment into the
observation camera outside of itself
before whipping the curtain shot Dr Ham
was discovered three hours later
crawling around the floor of zero four
nine South now another mindless Undead
when he was retrieved by security zero
four nine didn't even look up from his
notebook Dr Ham didn't get the
incinerator treatment but he did receive
a fatal dose of drugs and mercy a
removal team was sent to zero four nine
South but it had said there was no need
for special extraction techniques it
would go willingly wherever they wanted
to go it was not it said an enemy of the
people the Hippocratic Oath forbids me
to hurt a human being it said well
walking to the interrogation Center my
only design is to offer you my services
and expertise the floors and walls of
the interrogation Center room were
painted a bright white even the table
was white which contrasted with 049 a
massive black sitting in the middle of
the room during the interrogation it
refused to admit or even accept that it
had killed Dr hams I cured him I removed
the pestilence from his body it said it
was later asked if it regretted its
actions to which it replied well good
sir one always regrets the loss of a
colleague for any reason but I stand by
my actions the pestilence must be abated
before it is too late every two weeks
from that point zero four nine was given
animals the scientists at the facility
observed it time and again touching the
animals killing them before producing a
saw or scalpel and opening them up
organs would be carefully removed with
perfect Precision it was astounding to
even train surgeons just how talented
0-49 was I require a close relative of
yours said 049 one day to a young Doctor
Who expressed shock that it was asked
for one of the doctors family members I
mean a great Aid said zero four nine not
your dear Aunt there were several
instances of 049 displaying a crude
sense of humor staff would almost forget
that the thing that they were talking to
wasn't human almost and it was Dr Thomas
morester that had supplied the great
apes orangutans in fact that had been
rescued from the rainforests of Borneo
only to be taken to 049 South then one
day something changed 049 told Dr
morstead that its work was done that it
accomplished what it had wanted to do
and could someone remove the cured
animal from itself I think you'd find
that it's quite the work of art a
Triumph 049 said through the intercom
when the removal team entered the cell
they found the orangutan or what was
left of it it was lying in the corner of
the cell the top of its skull had been
removed leaving its brain Exposed on its
face was the expression of relaxation
and from its mouth it issued very soft
squeaks like that of an infant 049 said
tell Dr morrista that its rage mechanism
no longer exists I've removed the
amygdala and made some changes to the
hypothalamus and limbic system it is
cured and quite harmless the next day Dr
morstead announced that he wanted to
visit 049 cell himself after which he
heard a course of disapproval from his
colleagues all telling him that 049 was
now too dangerous Dr Ham was sick
replied more step and 049 has assured us
that he would never take another human
life he's never lied to us and I'm going
to take him at his word it appeared that
04 9 had created the perfect specimen so
what was next Dr Moore stood had to know
everyone is sick 049 told Dr morstead
after the two had talked for a couple of
minutes the great pandemic has started
fear not doctor I have a cure no longer
will you humans spread your disease I'm
afraid you are wrong but by the doctor
this pandemic you speak of does not
exist we can happily live with our
pathogens we have done so for Millennia
Dr morstead became angry that he
couldn't get through to zero four nine
I'm afraid you're suffering from
paranoia it is you who need to be cured
you have no idea sub-049 standing up
what are you doing shouted more stead
you promised you wouldn't hurt a human
again I'm not hurting you I'm healing
you 049 said and leapt across the room
in a Flash placing a hand on the
doctor's head morstead slumped to the
ground they were being watched in the
observation room and this had gone too
far he had to be moved to the contain
permanently mobile task force Epsilon 11
was right on the scene and burst through
the door now imagination 049 said to
himself those humans have no imagination
at all he began walking towards the task
force who opened fire on the anomaly but
the bullets bounced off its black code
and mask
scp-049 calmly touched each of the
members of the task force one by one
draining to life from them the last one
standing stopped firing and attempted to
run but again 049 left across the room
black cape billowing out behind him and
gently touched the man causing him to
drop to the floor zero four nine stepped
over the bodies of the Fallen team and
walked out of the containment cell the
full details of what happened next are
available only to the o5 council what
are sometimes called the overseers the
redacted report that is available reads
standard secure humanoid containment
cell research sector 0-2 site 19 subject
scp-049 data breach redacted Euclid
class scp-049 each cell and subsequently
gained access to adjoining rooms in
nearby buildings breach lasted
approximately three days and five hours
total casualties redacted with redacted
number of survivors requiring
incineration therapy course of action
Department of science Alchemy division
suggested injecting anti-transmorgraphy
disinfectant into class D former
prisoners who were transported to site
and allowed them to come into contact
with scp-049 SCP failed to reanimate
injected prisoners and cure them scp-049
acknowledged this failure and
surrendered to mobile task force alpha-1
scp-049 then requested to be contained
present containment under responsibility
of redacted redacted present location of
scp-049 redacted as you walk down the
halls of the SCP Foundation site 19
speaking in the various windows at the
anomalies contained there you might
catch a glimpse of a dark figure bent
over a table tinkering away like an
artisan in his Workshop a vintage black
Apothecary bag sits neck next to him
open and if you stop and watch for a
while you'll see him pull all manner of
tools out of it impossibly large tools
things that shouldn't fit in such a
small bag a bone saw an IV stand jars of
fluorescent liquids and needles the
length of your forearm you shouldn't be
surprised this is a place for impossible
things after all still it's a curious
sight the shadowy man working so
diligently so quietly focused singularly
on his craft whatever that might be only
one thing could distract him from his
efforts you he feels your Gaze on him
and he looks up dark eyes glittering
from behind a beaked ceramic mask he
reminds you of an illustration you once
saw in a book about the Black Death the
gear the plague doctors wore while
treating patients on their deathbeds
hello he greets you in a friendly
heavily accented voice his eyes crinkled
beneath the mask and if you could see
his mouth you you'd be smiling how are
you today dear fellow are you feeling
quite well he takes a step toward the
window stretching out one gloved hand
and you suddenly realize that you can't
see where the mask ends and his skin
begins it's not a mask but a part of his
face this is no ordinary man do you
require help I can examine you he offers
Palm press flat against the glass a
chill runs up your spine and you realize
that you should definitely not take him
up on his offer no matter how friendly
he seems how good his intentions may be
you wouldn't want to let the plague
doctor treat you he sat in his
containment cell fidgeting with his
favorite scalpel he dragged it over the
surface of his work table back and forth
listening to the sound it made they had
tried to confiscate his table his tools
the guards had quickly learned that he
had more of them in his bag they tried
to take away his bag from him but well
that didn't go over too well for anyone
involved so he was allowed to keep it to
Fashion himself a makeshift laboratory
in his lonely little cell there was a
time where they had given him test
subjects fresh corpses from the mourn
for him to dissect and research there
was a time when the doctors here would
come to speak with him talking of
cryptobiology and the pestilence he had
dedicated himself to fighting those days
were long gone he had hidden in the way
pieces of the corpses tissue samples and
jars of formaldehyde he could pull out
when the monotony became too much but
the days of fresh materials of
enlightened discourse with other men and
women of science were over
those days the chance to work with
others as he once had what had he done
wrong all he did was treat the sick sure
they didn't always understand their
illness didn't want to receive their
medicine but that wasn't a choice for
the patient to make that should have
been up to the physician perhaps they
didn't trust his expertise then see how
his work served the greater good like
those who watched Jonas Salk invent the
polio vaccine or Louis Pasteur with milk
of bacteria they were confused by the
advanced scientific practices and feared
that which they did not understand he
could forgive them for their ignorance
he was magnanimous that way if only they
would let him out of this infernal room
he could prove his work's Worth to them
he could cure them all begin a new era
of wellness and peace worldwide he
didn't exactly sleep but when he rested
on his little cot in the corner of the
room he dreamed of that future of a
world healed biased touch a knock at the
door stirred him from his reverie
someone someone was at the door of his
containment cell he glanced at the
little window and saw a guard there with
a tray of food he greeted the man with
an enthusiastic wave sustenance he
didn't require the food for survival of
course but it helped his mind work more
efficiently it reminded him of a time
before these fluorescent lights and
these same Four Walls of crusty bread
with fresh butter by the banks of the
Sun a little slot opened in the door and
the tray was shoved through there was
bread just as he hoped a small dish of
butter pot of jam and a cup of tea still
seeming he picked up the cup at first
taking a deep breath ah an herbal blend
with fresh lavender lovely he couldn't
see the guard through the window anymore
but he called out to him just the same
thank you for the Libations he still had
his manners after all even in
confinement he wished he could have
gotten a better look at the man seen the
power of His complex a Tremor in his
hand he thought he had spotted sweat
beating on his forehead could he be ill
the case required further examination to
be certain he sighed clutching the cup
of tea tighter in frustration why
wouldn't they just let him work why must
they scream at the sight of his efforts
flee from his instruments it didn't seem
fair still the pursuit of science rarely
was a glamorous one he had learned as
much over the centuries one day though
history would look back on him kindly of
this he could be certain he was just
settling in and beginning to spread
butter across the admittedly stale bread
when a horrible sound shook him to
attention he had heard the noise before
though he had never seen its source it
was an ear-splitting scream a whale of
pure Agony like the sound of a wounded
wild animal he had heard many many
screams during his life from patients
and those who stood in the way of his
work but until he had been brought into
cusp of the foundation he had never
heard a scream quite like this one it
was pure rage Devastation and suffering
mixed together wet with tears and loud
enough to rip through human vocal folds
whatever was crying out it was no mere
man more screams answered it and these
were very much human these sounds were
more familiar to him shrieks of pain of
fear of desperate but futile attempts to
escape then the meaty thought of bodies
falling to the floor of torn off limbs
hitting walls and windows a loud crash
and the sound of something large moving
quite quickly through the Halls
scientific curiosity got the better of
the doctor and he found himself moving
back to his little window face pressed
to the glass so hard his beak nearly
cracked it he couldn't see much of
anything just guards running down the
hall weapons drawn he saw one of them
fire for The Gunshot ring out but what
was he firing at then saw it a pale blur
darting past the door whatever it was it
didn't so much as Flinch when the bullet
ricocheted off its skin a long thin arm
crashed against the door knocking the
doctor backwards into his work table he
studied himself and climbed back to his
feet taking in the Damage Done to the
door it was crumpled in on itself nearly
ripped off the hinges and whatever had
plowed into it was already gone from the
sounds of Chaos in the distance it had
disappeared around the corner with the
guards following it he inspected the
ruins of the door to his containment
cell it was useless now hanging loose
and open well that was an invitation he
was hardly about to decline he grabbed
his trusty bag tossed his scalpel back
inside and set off to see what all the
commotion was it was easy enough to
follow the trail of blood Stark and
Vivid red against the white tile floor
and the sound of gunfire human screams
and that loud long painful whale he had
heard before he walked at a leisurely
Pace taking his time until the sound
suddenly stopped he rounded the corner
and found a mound of bodies guards and
scientists beaten and bloodied almost
beyond recognition it was quiet here
saved for one sound the sound of weeping
there in the corner huddled over with
its face to the wall was a pale thin
figure it shoulders heaving with the
force of its sobs this poor soul was
clearly in great distress it was a
peculiar sight hairless and white
distended arms wrapped around itself as
a cried excuse me the doctor cried out
to the pitiful creature are you all
right do you need assistance it didn't
answer it just continued to cry had
something so despondent been responsible
for this destruction the dozens of
corpses the smashed in walls the
crumbled doors and shattered Windows it
seemed impossible sure it was large and
looked strong but he had never seen a
monster cry before this couldn't be a
dangerous creature not when it was so
sad he would help it but first he would
attend to some of these bodies he sat
his bag on the ground and pulled out
several vials of liquid a set of
syringes and a variety of other surgical
tools he might need now after such a
long Hiatus he could resume his work in
a meaningful way he couldn't be certain
how long he worked Reviving these poor
souls and reconstructing their bodies as
the pale creature wept in the corner the
sobbing faded into the background for a
while becoming a kind of white noise as
he removed a liver here placed it in a
chest cavity there poked and prodded
injected and extracted testing out new
methods alongside tried and true cures
One By One The Milky eyes fluttered open
rigor mortis stiff joints creaked into
motion sallow faces looking at his with
the vacant gratitude he saw in so many
patients over the years he didn't need
to thank him with their words the work
was its own reward he expected more
guards to arrive to attempt to contain
the situation but none came even as the
alarm blared overhead as for the morose
creature it didn't seem to notice his
presence at all not even when he had
brought all of the intact corpses back
to life the patient shuffled around the
room aimlessly waiting for orders of
some kind the doctor tapped one on the
shoulder and handed the reborn man a
vial of thick black medicine give this
to the poor fellow in the corner please
it wasn't much but it should calm him
provide some relief from his Suffering
The Corpse nodded mouth hanging loose
and open and Eyeball dangling unseen
from the socket he shuffled over to the
strange creature and held out the vial
to it it turned lifting its head and as
it locked eyes with the cured patient
something shifted in its face its mouth
opened wide impossibly wide
and a treat that same terrible sound as
before tears stream from its colorless
eyes its arms shaking with unbridled
rage as its jaws locked around the
patient's head like a boa constrictor in
one fluid motion it swallowed the
revived man whole while the doctor
watched in shock he had been wrong this
was not an innocent creature caught in
the wrong place at the wrong time this
creature whatever it was was deeply sick
he had never seen such an advanced
aggressive case of the pestilence he'd
heard rumors of course but never
encountered it firsthand as a doctor he
had sworn to do no harm but in a drastic
situation drastic measures have to be
taken it was well known by himself and
the doctors at this Foundation that he
could cause any and all biological
functions in an organism to cease with a
single touch and so he approached the
creature arm outstretched ready to
administer that necessary touch to
protect the rest of his patient as he
approached the creature turned to him
its eyes wide and blank an endless
stream of Tears pouring from them
spilling onto the floor it shrieked
again mouth stretching wide enough to
engulf his entire head and ran toward
him at a Breakneck speed I am so sorry
you are not well the doctor said simply
as his hand pressed to the creature's
chest as soon as the tough hide of the
doctor's hand which the uninformed might
mistake for gloves made contact with the
unpigmented skin of the Beast its eyes
closed its muscles went slack and it
collapsed to the ground with a mighty
thud the doctor paced around the Fallen
creature taking in the sight then
something strange caught his eye the
creature's chest still Rose and fell was
it his imagination he checked its pulse
and thought it was slow and faint and
though was slow and faint it was very
much present the creature was still
alive it had merely been rendered
unconscious by a touch rather than
completely deceased curious very curious
indeed he muttered perhaps there were
comorbidities present other infections
aside from the pestilence which rendered
the creature unnaturally strong
resilient to the usual courses of
treatment what would cause these
abilities this intense aggression it
seemed to be brought on whenever someone
looked at the entity's face if only he
studied psychology more the science of
the mind and its inner workings since he
had no experience with therapy nor was
he certain this creature could
communicate using language at all there
was only one way to find out more about
how this creature's brain worked he
would have to take it apart and see for
himself it was slow work getting the
massive creature back to the doctor's
containment cell it required the help of
his cured patients who grasped it by its
massive Limbs and dragged the limp body
through the Halls once back in a
familiar environment his work table
ready and waiting the doctor instructed
his assistance to place the new patient
on the table it was a bit small unable
to accommodate the creature's distended
limbs but if he attempted to use an
official Foundation Laboratory he risked
Discovery and subsequent Interruption so
it would have to suffice first he set up
an IV stand filled with a vivid green
liquid it was easy to find a vein the
creature's skin was nearly translucent
now that he could be certain the
creature would not wake during surgery
he could make the first incision scalpel
be held out of hand and his favorite
surgical blade was placed in it by one
of the helpful patients thank you he
slid the scalpel along the hairline of
the creature or where the hairline would
be if it weren't completely bald once
the scalp was removed he set it aside
for later when it could be reattached
bone saw please he held out his hand
again and again his assistant gave him
the proper tool this however was when
things got strange the doctor had always
been a Deft hand at cutting he'd once
even received tutelage from the great
Robert Liston but no matter how hard he
tried to saw it never left a scratch on
the creature's skeleton naturally this
was somewhat frustrating he wanted to
study the creature's brain tissue to get
a sense for what was going up there
neurologically and he couldn't do that
if it was impossible to saw off the
creature's cranial cap he blunted two of
his favorite saws while trying
thankfully there was still a solution to
access the beast's gray matter a little
trick he'd learned while studying the
funerary practices of the ancient
Egyptians he produced a long curved Hook
from his bag and in it up the creature's
nasal passage with some fine maneuvering
he eventually managed to remove the
brain it was such a terrible shame that
he needed to do it piece by piece via
the nasal passage but one makes do all
that was left was to sew the skin of the
creature's head back into place it was
mid-stitch when a voice interrupted his
careful work nearly making him drop the
needle hey what are you doing he looked
up to find a guard aiming a gun at his
face excuse me I am in surgery at the
moment please do not interrupt he
admonished the guard but the man did not
listen or lower his weapon in fact he
shouted something into the radio code
words the doctor didn't recognize then
he fired a bullet into the skull of the
patient standing at his side how dare
you the doctor cried readying himself to
confront the guard but it was too late
dozens of other guards were swarming the
room and neutralizing his assistance
some in hazmat suits grabbed his arms
and pulled him away from the creature on
the operating table no matter how hard
he fought or how loudly he protested
then something incredible happened
something wonderful the creature opened
its eyes and sat up it looked directly
at the guard closest to it and the two
saw one another's faces the guard tensed
preparing for the worst but nothing came
the creature simply stared Placid and
quiet no screaming no tearing of Flesh
no mouth opening wider and wider to
swallow the manhole I did it the doctor
shouted overcome with Elation I've cured
you now Begins the rest of your happy
life he watched as the guards led the
shockingly calm creature away back to
its containment cell the doctor's door
was repaired and he was returned to his
state of captivity but he never forgot
the patient he helped that day and how
marvelous it felt to do such a good deed
meanwhile
scp-096's brain regrew within the hour
and caused another massive Containment
Breach murdering a variety of
researchers and guards the staff agreed
not to tell scp-049 about any of this
better to just let him have this one he
really seemed like he needed a win
please good sir I beseech you as a man
of science nay as a man of reason you
mustn't stifle my research at this
critical juncture you have no idea how
close I am to finding a cure for this
blasted pestilence I need only a handful
of Life subjects to complete my research
the plague doctors emphatic pleas fell
on deaf ears as a stone face researcher
took notes on his latest pontifications
the doctor whom these clods had reduced
so rudely to a mere number as cp049
banged his gloved fist up against the
wall and to think he once thought of
these men as intellectual equals fellow
Travelers on the road to Scientific
Enlightenment what a positively sick
joke before the doctor got another
chance to appeal for his right to
experiment the researcher left him alone
once more a truly sad State of Affairs
nobody appreciated a true scientist in
this day and age it was sure to be
another day of languishing alone in this
cell wishing he had the capacity to do
more so he was surprised as anyone when
the alarm started going off and the door
of his cell swung open automatically the
plague doctor stepped out of his cell
and into the Hall where many other
humanoid anomalies were roaming confused
as to why they'd been suddenly released
what was happening as it turned out what
was happening was one of the most brutal
chaos Insurgency raids the staff of site
19 had ever seen it had been planned
immaculately you see guards rotate
semi-regularly at site 19 due to the
high pressure nature of the job lots of
deaths and mental breakdowns as you
probably correctly predicted even the
administrative staff of the SCP
Foundation are only human well mostly
anyway so they're not immune to little
oversights here and there and it's in
those oversights that expertly train
chaos Insurgency infiltration agents
make their living no less than 15 of
them had been working undercover in site
19 for just over two weeks and they did
a fine job of lowering the metaphorical
drawbridge for a heavily armed Invasion
Force the guards who weren't plants were
quickly murdered by the infiltrators and
even some of the on-site task forces
were quickly overwhelmed and gunned down
by the high Precision rifles of the
chaos insurgency's finest while the
frontliners were distracted by the
sudden assault the infiltrators found
their way to the site security control
room and massacred everyone inside
opening every single door in the site
was as simple as putting in a few stolen
key codes and flipping a few carefully
remembered switches consequently while
Foundation agents and cast Insurgency
mercenaries Clash Sabers high priority
anomalies like scp-049 simply wandered
the facility watching the Calamity
unfold within the foundation was beset
on all sides shot at by heavily armed
maniacs and attacked from within by the
numerous roaming anomalous entities that
were eager to get their hands on
Foundation Personnel definitely not an
ideal situation to say the least the
plague doctor only had one thing on his
mind though hmm these definitely want to
do my research any good unless I can
escape and find my way to a suitable
laboratory oh now there is an idea but
his scientific fantasies were soon
interrupted by a chaos Insurgency
Soldier swinging the butt of his M4
carbine into his avian exoskull with a
supremely unpleasant crack the doctor
was Dazed by it momentarily the pain
coming at him like a Thunderclap but the
Insurgent never got the chance to to
take another swing before the Insurgent
could do anything the plague doctor
lunged out with practice speed grasping
him by the throat immediately everything
went black and the insurgent's limp
corpse collapsed to the ground sir the
doctor internally mused soldiers
attacking Medics is violating even the
most basic rules of gentlemanly warfare
then another flash of immense pain has a
different rifle butt collided with the
back of his head the doctor fell to one
knee feeling dizzy but before he could
retaliate he felt the two sharp prongs
of a cattle prod pressing up against his
neck the Sudden Rush of electricity
surged through his neck sending his
muscles into a wave of involuntary
spasms the insurgents crowding around
him chimed in with their own agonizing
cattle prods relentlessly shocking him
until the flashes of white hot pain soon
became an oppressive blanket of total
dark even on his most cantankerous days
the SCP Foundation had never treated him
like this when he eventually came to he
was still in darkness standing upright
with high-tech shackles holding every
limb in place it was beyond
uncomfortable for the poor plague doctor
but it succeeded in the task of keeping
him under control he couldn't move an
inch there were muffled voices beyond
the dark beyond the confines of this new
containment the modulated gas mask
voices of insurgents and something else
faintly accented oddly familiar but he
couldn't quite place it soon the voices
were replaced by another sound the
grinding of crowbars Levering Nails out
of cheap wood with a creaking tumble a
rectangle of bright light opened up in
front of him populated by a number of
silhouettes on either side were chaos
insurgents in familiar tactical Garb and
in between them stood a tall
well-groomed man with an expensive
looking purple smoking jacket and a
pencil mustache for a few fractions of a
second his face was a portrait of
excitement but as he took in the sight
of the plague doctor standing before him
all the joy drained from his snooty
continents what the hell am I looking at
here the man in the smoking jacket said
the doctor indignant I had such a
response from the man who'd presumably
ordered his assault rasped a man of
science could sir the man in the smoking
jacket ignored him and continued to
berate the chaos insurgents with an odd
level of confidence for someone
reprimanding trained cold-blooded
Killers I wanted scp-650 the startling
statue not this clownish Ren Fair
cosplayer what the hell did I pay you
Ruffians for I was told you chaos
insurgents were the very best at this
and for your FD price I expect
Excellence the rent continued much like
this leaving everyone in attendance the
insurgents the plague doctor feeling
thoroughly exhausted by him and unable
to do anything about it you see this
wasn't just any chaos Insurgency client
your average tin pot dictator or arms
dealer you know the time this was the
one and only pass skull legat one of the
most famous or rather Infamous anarch
collectors in the game he'd been a
founding Person of Interest for years
due to his dealings with the chaos
Insurgency and Marshall Carter and Doc
limited all to the end of expanding his
anarch collection but his vast wealth
and connections had always shielded him
from Foundation probes for those
unfamiliar with the subculture an art
short for anomalous art is exactly what
it sounds like artistic projects with
anomalous properties to give it that
extra kick one of the most popular
groups of Interest dealing in an art is
the iconic are we cool yet which
incidentally had recently excommunicated
Pascal Legette for being an exceedingly
wealthy uptight Square who really didn't
represent the collective's rebellious
ethos and considering his response was
to pay the chaos Insurgency to raid site
19 for a few pieces for his own private
collection costing him millions of
dollars in both groups many lives it was
safe to say he wasn't taking it well
look we got you that understand at you
and that thing killed four of our best
guys so how about we just call it even
said one of the insurgents I'm sure you
can have fun with bird brain here too
Pascal tunned it and reluctantly
dismissed the higher guns having the
plague doctor here definitely wasn't
ideal especially considering he wanted
to host the ultimate an art exhibition
to put are we cool yet worthless
magnific to shame but he would make do
with what he had perhaps he could say
that 049 was a commentary on the
ever-present nature of disease in
Mankind's life and our forever archaic
approach to it yes yes that would do
nicely needless to say the plague doctor
was infuriated by all this the violence
against his person the kidnapping the
disrespect and most of all the
interruption to his precious research
especially considering how close he'd
gotten to finding a cure for the
pestilence but instead he was soon
spirited by a legion of heavily armed
goons from his wooden box to a glass one
in one of legette's many opulent
hallways there were other glass cases on
either side of him and more on the other
side of the hall all too reinforced for
the plague doctor to even smash through
it on his own damn it legette's own
private and art exhibition probably
wedged between his oversized dining room
and his jewel encrusted crapper
occasionally Pascal himself would jaunt
down the hallway to gaze upon his new
stolen anarch pieces and of course the
plague doctor would try his best to
reason with him I am a patient man this
is simply barbaric by what right do you
imprison me here is your intention to
deprive the world the entire human race
of my valuable medical breakthroughs
could you live with that on your
conscience good sir there was never any
meaningful response the plague doctors
soon learned that Pascal Legette didn't
like his art interactive it was simply
meant to languish away in a glass box
being watched being passively looked at
those chaos Insurgency louds hadn't even
bothered to bring his notebook or
medical back like so he was without the
tools to even perform his experiments as
loathed as he was to admit it this was
even worse than being mocked up by the
SCP Foundation but all this wasn't
entirely unfamiliar there was something
in the glass box across from the plague
doctor that he vaguely recognized back
from site 19. he'd never seen it up
close but he'd heard researchers
speaking about it and even seen a few
pictures and such a strange construction
it was a peculiar haphazard sculpture
made from concrete rebar and spray paint
quite ugly in this humble doctor's
opinion but there was something oddly
entrancing about it and for reasons
beyond the doctor's recollection four of
legette's men stood around the glass box
in where it was being stored always
watching the man were frequently
switched in and out as though they were
watching in shifts always fixing their
Gaze on its peculiar malformed body
maybe it was all the electrical shocks
and knocks to the head but he just
couldn't remember why Pascal was having
the piece so carefully observed but he
knew on some Primal level that the
secret to this would perhaps be the key
to his own Escape if only he could
remember still time passed Pascal
drifted in and out sometimes with guests
the plague doctor had learned not to
speak these animals could not be
reasoned with as a scientist he would
instead carefully observe until his
observations bore fruit he noticed that
Pascal's guests all people who looked
equally as wealthy and pompous as Pascal
himself all seemed to look right over
him and instead focus on the ugly statue
across the hall still forever observed
by any four of Pascal's men some of them
looked actively nervous just being in
its presence curious the plague doctor
made a mental note of this just as he
did when Pascal gave his guests a
reassuring pat on the shoulder and told
them please calm yourself it's harmless
while my Personnel are keeping an eye on
it little by little the plague doctor's
memories of his Infamous neighbor had
begun to return he knew what he must do
to escape now all he needed to do was
wait for the perfect moment soon enough
Pascal's mention was filled with a bevy
of anarch snobs from hither and yarn a
private Soiree to show off his new
collection they wandered the halls in
three-piece Tuxedos and designer
ballroom dresses sipping champagne from
imported Crystal all such lovely refined
High Society people and if the good
doctor's plan went off as he intended
they would all be such lovely refined
High Society corpses the plague doctor
waited until mercifully he and the four
members of personnel watching the
sculpture were the only ones left in the
hallway he'd been so good so patient
that none of the men guarding the
sculpture at present had ever heard him
make a noise he was so invisible to them
that in all likelihood they probably
didn't even notice he could make a sound
and Matt worked for his purposes just
fine though in any case if he wanted
this to work he would need to time his
plan perfectly even a fraction of a
second out of place and the whole thing
would have dire consequences still the
doctor was still a Frenchman at heart
and as a Frenchman he knew he would
rather die nobly in the process of
Escape than remain captured by this
worthless buffoon he'd be sure to take
as many of these men down with him in
the process as he was able the plague
doctor exhaled deeply drawing a lung
full of air then bellowed as loud as he
possibly could the sudden unexpected
noise was so shocking that it jogged the
four Watchers almost reflexively to turn
and look at him and in the split second
that they did the plague doctor closed
his eyes in the dark times seemed to
move slower perhaps due to the doctor's
Keen Focus cultivated over many a
century he listened carefully to the
sequence of sounds glass shattering four
choked gasps in sequence four brutal
crunches then nanoseconds later more
glass shattering the plague doctor's
eyes snapped open just in time just as
predicted the sculpture being entirely
unobserved had smashed through its glass
case murdering all four members of
personnel by snapping their necks and
then smashed through his own glass case
to do the same to him the plague doctor
had cut it so close in fact that he
opened his eyes to the face of the
sculpture staring into his own its
concrete limbs wrapped around his neck
very good timing indeed with a sigh of
relief the plague doctor slipped out of
the sculpture's concrete grasp and
backed down the hallway keeping his gaze
fixed stun the sculpture the entire time
he had heard it decimate Pascal's men he
certainly didn't fancy undergoing the
same fate the second the plague doctor
backed around the corner rendering the
sculpture or as the SCP Foundation
called it SCP-173 out of sight he could
hear terrified screaming coming from the
other end of the hall he was not a
sadistic man but the the plague doctor
would be lying if he told you he didn't
take just a little bit of pleasure in
hearing that sound somewhere else in the
vast Mansion of Pascal Legette the
sculpture was slaughtering its way
through servants and party guests while
the plague doctor searched for some kind
of exit anyone who dared getting in his
way was given a Swift and merciless
Touch of death sending their body
unceremoniously to the ground anyone in
his way was preventing him from finding
a cure for the pestilence and thus
endangering countless lives it was of
course regrettable to have to kill
anyone but some sacrifices must be made
for the greater good of mankind well
it's not necessarily always regrettable
per se on his way out while the
murderous Rampage of SCP-173 seemed to
distract anyone of note the plague
doctor just so happened to encounter a
fleeing Pascal Legette hoping to find
some kind of Escape himself it seemed
that now fate was on his side once more
to have his Jailer right here in the
palm of his hand would be such a perfect
Parting Gift funnily enough Pascal was
far more talkative to him now he rattled
off a rapid-fire series of threats
bribes and pleas claiming in the end
that he never meant any harm he was the
one who freed the plague doctor from the
SCP Foundation they were on the same
side here all this was for the art no
offense was ever intended Haskell
Legette simply lived for art then die
for it good sir the plague doctor said
and with a single touch Pascal's eyes
rolled up into the back of his head and
he fell to the ground dead it was one of
the few non-scientific deaths that he
felt truly no guilt for after some time
searching the screams around the rest of
the Mansion eventually went silent that
did wonders for his focus it didn't take
long for the plague doctor to locate an
exit a fine mahogany door with elaborate
adornments befitting a man as gaudia's
Pascal and began strolling towards it
his chest swollen with pride and a sense
of accomplishment then he blinked and a
few feet in front of him stood the
sculpture it was there so suddenly that
the plague doctor fell backwards in
shock but he devoted everything to
keeping an eye on that monstrosity with
everyone else in the Mansion presumably
dead at this point it had now come back
for him it stood there staring silently
ready to exact the terrible price for
freeing it as soon as the doctor dared
to Blink the plague doctor began
crawling backwards down the hall just
wanting to put some distance between
himself and the sculpture as the seconds
passed he could feel his eyes drying out
until the inevitable blink the sculpture
was standing right in front of him now
gazing down almost mocking it had closed
the distance so quickly if the plague
doctor blinked again he was sure that
his eyes would never open again all it
had to do was wait as the seconds passed
and the doctor began to feel his eyes
drying up again that subtle sting
quickly grew into a nagging pain that
could not be denied sooner later he was
going to have to bang the front door
flew open and in an instant the hallway
was filled with heavily armed troops all
wearing the familiar black and gray of
the SCP Foundation the plague doctor had
never been so relieved to see the
organization that had kept him locked up
for so many decades for once they'd
saved him from something even worse of
course the sculpture didn't say anything
but the disappointment of losing that
one more victim seemed to radiate off of
it like a lingering bad smell the plague
doctor willingly gave himself up and
heavy machinery was brought in to pick
up SCP-173 with the help of the iPods to
make sure it didn't try any funny
business in transit Pascal had gotten
away with his Shady dealings for years
but the Brazen attack he funded against
site 19 was now enough for the
foundation to track him down when his
corpse was found in the halls of his own
home with no obvious cause of death we
can happily tell you that nobody was
disappointed by the evening the plague
doctor was happy to be back in his cell
his research could continue here and in
time he knew that the Personnel of the
SCP Foundation would listen to reason
and comply with his demands after all
science Marches On regardless of who
chooses to march with it but he would
forever feel a little nervous in site 19
after that knowing the concrete monster
he was sharing the building with he
hoped that if ever there was another
Containment Breach involving that thing
that it didn't feel like paying him a
visit for old time's sake
scp-049 also known as the plague doctor
is an SCP Foundation fan favorite This
Charming anomalous surgeon can terrify
with a glance and kill with a touch in
terms of his Origins his methods and his
thought process around a disease he
calls the pestilence this is one of the
most mysterious scps out there and
thankfully we didn't have to investigate
this one alone we made a community post
asking you the fans of Best CP explained
to give us your questions and theories
about the good doctor that we all hope
doesn't give house calls and you didn't
disappoint let's grab our masks and hand
sanitizer and take a look at what you
had to say about
scp-049 first the questions Bob candle
asked why does he refuse to tell
researchers about the pestilence that's
a good question and also one of the
biggest mysteries surrounding 049's lore
for the uninitiated the pestilence also
known as the great dying is the nickname
given to an unknown disease that scp-049
has dedicated his life to curing
whatever curing means to him when asked
by Foundation researchers 049 refuses to
give up even the most basic information
about the pestilence such as how he
diagnoses it what its effects are or how
it's transmitted it seems that part of
the reason that 049 refuses to tell
researchers about it is that he
apparently assumes that they as fellow
doctors inherently know what he's
talking about when he brings up the
pestilence he has acted with confusion
and frustration during questioning and
049 seems to believe that the pestilence
is such common knowledge among medical
practitioners that it would be a waste
of time to explain it if he even had the
words to do so dadgamer 56 asked why is
he so Cooperative if humans have the
pestilence he wants to cure so bad one
of the most remarkable things about 049
is how reasonable he's been with
Foundation staff in the past he's polite
friendly and treats his jailers as
equals when he's not murdering them and
turning them into zombies but that is a
good question if he believes humans have
the pestilence why is he so Cooperative
with them thankfully the answer here is
simple while 049 believes that the
pestilence is widespread he doesn't
believe that every human is carrying it
in fact when he was first contained by
the foundation and brought into an SCP
facility he complimented the staff on
how little little pestilence there was
inside the building compared to the
outside while we don't know what lead
049 to think a person is healthy or
diseased we do know there is a
distinction and he's Cooperative with
those he sees as healthy star doggo
gaming asked how would he interact with
610 AKA The Flesh that hates I wonder if
he would view the infected as pestilence
another great question 610 is an
extremely dangerous sarkic SCP that
presents as a zombie-like virus that
causes horrific fleshy mutations because
of the extremely high infection rate of
the flesh that hates it's been
quarantined in its present location in
the isolated Siberian Wilderness while
it would be too dangerous to bring
anyone or anything into contact with the
flesh we're betting that 049 would find
the flesh utterly repulsive whether even
he would be able to cure this horrific
infection is another question the flesh
that hates is best left alone at all
costs m cifer 50 asked
scp-049's notebook appears to be written
in a language no human can decipher
could another SCP like 343 or 662 decode
The Notebook the answer to this is a
solid maybe these two scps known as God
and Mr Deeds respectively may be able to
translate the contents of 049's
mysterious leather-bound notebook the
problem is given that we've seen 049 is
a pretty terrible doctor when it comes
to anything other than raising mutant
zombies from the dead the contents of
his notebook might just be as useless as
the interviews with him have proven to
be that said it probably is worth a try
just to find out if he's actually been
pretending to write this whole time
Green Angel snake YT asked do other
living creatures like pigs cats or
literally any animal have this thing he
calls the pestilence what even are the
living things he considers cured to the
best of our knowledge 049 only believes
humans can contract the pestilence how
do we know this this leads us to our
next question Mia the hot dog asked if
he touches the immortal lizard will the
lizard die and be rid of disease or will
the lizard be immune or will it attack
the doctor the foundation did attempt to
terminate 682 with 049 but the effort
was unsuccessful zero four nine when
encountering the lizard commented that
only humans can contract the pestilence
when he tried to touch 682 the lizard
swiped at him with its claws 049 then
requested to leave and later interviews
revealed that the plague doctor felt
emotionally disturbed by his time with
682 gamer duck YT asked where did he
originally come from well evidence
suggests that 049 is extremely old and
very well traveled he was first
discovered by the foundation in the town
of montebaum in southern France given
that he speaks fluent medieval French as
his first language it's safe to assume
that France is probably his country of
origin and could have existed for
hundreds of years if not longer
interestingly his famous plague doctor
appearance is more similar to those
first worn by Italian doctors in the
17th century which only deepens the
mystery of
scp-049 Garrett eborn asked why does he
insist that he isn't doing harm when
he's clearly in violation of his
Hippocratic Oath 049 does seem to regret
the harm he causes but he also believes
that the small sacrifices are necessary
in the quest to cure the pestilence also
a fun little history lesson given that
049's knowledge of medicine appears to
be medieval meaning potentially as early
as the 5th Century he actually would
have predated the Hippocratic Oath
coming into Universal use by doctors
which didn't become widespread until the
19th century despite the oath itself
first being created around 400 BC
Phoenix Fain asked if he has to wear
gloves of any kind would he still kill
you all evidence seems to point to no
only skin to skin contact with 049 is
fatal so a good pair of gloves could
really be a lifesaver Alice Verdugo
asked what would happen if he went one
on one with a shy guy would he cure him
or not do anything well we can't know
for sure because scp-096 aka the shy guy
isn't human it's likely that 049
wouldn't even consider him infected if
the two came into contact it would
probably result in a stalemate much like
the time scp-096 faced off against
scp-682 however if it did come to blows
between the two 096 is undeniably a much
more dangerous combatant and may be able
to narrowly defeat the plague doctor in
a direct confrontation while in its rage
State anything goes asked if he died
could he bring himself back to life or
have something prepared to bring himself
back to life like a lot of anomalies it
seems that 049 is abnormally hard to
kill given that he's seemingly
impervious to most physical damage
however seeing a 049s resurrection is
both a lengthy medieval process and
never brings its subjects back correctly
it's likely that if someone could
successfully put 049 down he wouldn't
get back up I'm not coming asked we know
that doctors are wearing masks to
protect patients but is his mask part of
his skull or face all of 049's clothes
including his plague doctor mask are
technically part of his body the mask is
part of its bone structure and the other
clothes are like layers of skin which
leads us nicely to the next question
Requiem asked if the clothing around him
is skin does he shut it we're not sure
but it's definitely a thought we all
wish we could forget
God now let's take a look at some of
your more interesting theories Clarence
Eileen theorized pestilence is sin and
he's trying to take it away this is
certainly an interesting Theory while we
can't find much in his file that
suggests 049 views the pestilence as a
result of sinful Behavior or the concept
of sin itself it's worth considering
that his medical background seems to
come from medieval times Medical Science
was in its infancy back then and many
still believe that diseases were the
result of loose morals or even demonic
interference so there might be some
truth to this Theory Thomas has
theorized I feel like he isn't really
bad all he wants to do is help and cure
everyone but his cure is death if we're
defining bad as a malicious desire to
cause harm for its own sake then this
Theory holds a lot of water for all
intents and purposes it does seem that
049 does genuinely want to cure his
patients of the pestilence and he does
seem to express remorse when they die
however by his own admission his cure is
imperfect and he hasn't found full
success in curing the disease without
causing death yet cat and dog live
theorized the plague doctor has seen the
end of the world and travels in a loop
back in time aiming to eventually stop
it the pestilence is the way each
human's impact on the end of the world
is and once he touches their flesh they
realize this and die of the realization
of what they've done the plague doctor
may be looking for a human or an SCP
that is pestilence-free for what reason
we don't know we don't have an awful lot
to say about this one because there's no
real evidence either way but given that
time travel does seem to be possible in
the SCP Foundation Universe it's a cool
possibility that we definitely can't
rule out it does however leave a lot of
loose ends about the gaps in 049's
knowledge such as the fact he doesn't
know about the Black Death Vladimir
Lenin theorized he's the best doctor
ever he cures depression pestilence and
sometimes his patients even come back
from the dead 5 star rating this is
certainly an extremely charitable way to
view
scp-049 one that he himself would likely
very much appreciate however considering
he changes his patients into mindless
zombified mutants a better course of
action may just be to attend therapy
chaotix theorized the pestilence is
death he is literally trying to cure
death while this could be one
interpretation of y-049 resurrects his
patients as zombies death is something
that affects all living non-anomalous
humans and 049 seems to be selective on
which humans it identifies as being
infected with the pestilence as a result
it is unlikely that the pestilence
refers to death itself and death is also
likely a preferable alternative to being
turned into a zombie by zero four nines
experimental treatments the blue
Guardian theorized the pestilence is an
entity in our Collective unconsciousness
described in
scp-5000 y this is an extremely
interesting Theory and one that could
hold water too if you check out our
series on scp-5 you'll find that the
foundation discovered a being known as
it hiding inside the collective
unconsciousness of humankind while the
foundation doesn't know about this in
our Dimension it's possible that scp-049
does and simply doesn't realize that
everyone is infected with it yet but if
this is the case an scp-049 realizes
that the whole world is infected he's
likely to become a much more dangerous
anomaly that refuses to cooperate with
anyone moonleaf's 430 theorized the
pestilence is the foundation and 049 is
a disciple of the Scarlet King this is
another incredibly fun Theory however
there are two big problems the first is
that 049 has historically identified
people with no Foundation affiliation as
being infected with the pestilence and
the second even more important issue is
that scp-049 is a highly scientific
creature whereas the Scarlet King hates
the very idea of science with a burning
passion as a result adult
scp-049 and the Scarlet King are likely
natural enemies and finally zerothrax
theorized his theme song should probably
be Gangsta's Paradise it's just a
speculation though on this Theory we
wholeheartedly agree and there you have
it thanks to everybody who sent in their
great questions and theories about
scp-049 keep an eye on our community
pose to see what anomalous entity we
need your thoughts on next got an SCP
you'd really like us to cover in a video
like this in the future let us know down
in the comments and remember to stay
safe and healthy because if you start
feeling a little under the weather you
can expect a visit from
scp-049 sometime soon the day is January
5th 2012. at an undisclosed off-site
location Dr Bannon leaves home and
begins his commute to work while in the
car he plays a video on his phone of his
12 year old's birthday party from the
previous night this side of it makes him
smile he would need that smile he
thought as today was not like any other
today was different he had been anxious
about the coming day for several weeks
now ever since the near unanimous vote
by the o5 council that the containment
chamber of scp-106 was to be reopened
the opportunity was too great to be
wasted they said the research that could
be gained too tempting studying
scp-106's molecular makeup its unique
ability to open a pocket Dimension or
even just the black sludge-like
substance that appeared whenever the
subject traveled through solid objects
was far too valuable to science to be
outweighed by its potential for danger
he pleaded with them begged them but as
Dr Bannon and his team of seven
researchers and accompaniment of 40
security Personnel began applying their
protective equipment he couldn't help
but think that he could have done more
to stop this only God knew how hard he
had tried to make them see reason he had
seen what it happened in previous
containment breaches at the facility he
had seen what had done to the poor
members of the SCP staff that became its
victims Fates worse than death limbs a
mangled mess of melted fused skin faces
sunken and Hollow with eyes and tongues
burned out he shuddered to think of what
would happen if containment failed again
this time but despite his misgivings he
knew full well that regardless of his
participation This research Mission
would go on with or without him and no
one knew as much about containing
scp-106 than he did slowly they
proceeded to dismantle each of the
containment facilities outer barriers 16
separate circular Chambers surrounded as
cp106's intercontainment facility each
filled with a variety of different
fluids fluids in each chamber varied in
consistency and viscosity from ionized
water to ammonia to kerosene
scp-106 had the peculiar ability to be
able to change its molecular makeup cup
to meld with objects and phase through
solid forms like walls and doors it
could literally melt into the space
between walls this made containing
scp-106 almost impossible by
conventional methods liquids confuse the
creature enough to slow him down in
theory anyways the secondary containment
Chambers were a recent addition to the
facility since the breach incident three
years ago Dr Bannon had been a new
addition to the research staff then he
had joined the team with bright eyes and
a desire to use their research to help
Society little did he know he would
instead do everything in his power to
keep whatever they found from ever
leaving the facility back then a breach
in the containment of scp-106 led to
countless deaths of SCP Personnel when a
researcher working on the top floor of
the outer layer of the containment
facility a knowing of the danger they
were in brought his child to work one
day it was thought that the outer layers
of the facility were enough to be
considered a safe Zone from the inner
Vault that was as CP p106's containment
but it wasn't enough to stop the old man
scp-106 preferred human prey between the
ages of 10 and 25 and the sound of a
child's cry or yell was enough to
capture its immediate attention what
preceded was unimaginable horror but
despite the unfortunate events of the
previous breach the Expedition continued
their descent into the bowels of the
building after several hours of draining
individual fluid Chambers one by one and
inputting complex codes and biometric
scans from simultaneous top security
clearance Personnel at a time the
Expedition team had eventually reached
the lower levels of
scp-106's containment facility suspended
in midair by ELO IID electromagnetic
supports in the center of a vast
Subterranean chamber was a massive
lead-line steel Cube 40 layers thick
each layer separated by 36 centimeters
of empty space with support struts
between layers randomly spaced to
confuse scp-106 from being able to phase
through one layer to the next
surrounding the cube on every surface
were military-grade automated light
systems capable of 80 000 lumens a piece
spaced every two feet around the
perimeter of the inner containment
chamber the team felt the resolve chip
away the closer they got to the
suspended creature Dr Bannon motioned to
overhead surveillance cameras above the
cube and waited slowly the cube was
lower to the ground until it hit the
floor with a soft thud that lightly
rumbled the ground above the Expedition
team's feet with a resentful look at the
Red Dot on the camera above Dr Bannon
initiated the release protocol all seven
researchers inputted their key cards and
submitted themselves to retina scans as
the 40 security Personnel established
defensive positions on every side of the
lead line Cube for a moment everyone
held their breath in silence you could
almost feel the thumping of everyone's
nervous heartbeats as they looked on to
Dr Bannon as he pulled out card everyone
knew that as soon as it was scanned the
barrier between them and the old man
would no longer exist if the rest of the
Personnel could see bannon's hand
shaking as he gripped the key card
tightly between his fingers it would
cause a possible mass panic among the
whole team as the spearheading
researcher on the job that day Bannon
knew what he was up against just the
same as everyone else if not more he
knew he couldn't show the fear that was
pulsing through his veins this wasn't
his first rodeo here at the foundation
he took a moment to collect his thoughts
get a hold of yourself Bannon he thought
Dr Bannon took a deep breath and scanned
the card the door slowly opened armed
with powerful rifle length flashlights
the researchers cautiously waded into
the dark entrance of the large Cube
inside the structure they found a cell
with a solid steel door signs of
corrosion could be seen on the door's
handle and from the outer walls of the
cell rust and rotted iron but no
breaches in the Integrity of the cell
there were no more security codes at the
store it was a simple round metal turn
lock Dr Bannon swallowed and began to
turn the handle open the sound of metal
echoed through the chamber as the door
creaked open each of the researchers
immediately pointed their flashlights
into the room there on the corner
standing motionless and undisturbed
stood
scp-106 the old man he stood with eyes
closed locked in a dormant State the
researchers had planned for this
scp-106 spent up to three months at a
time in this subdued state in between
periods of otherwise agitation where it
would lash out at its containment and
attempt to breach the research team
wasted no time they began to collect
data on the creature's biological makeup
taking whatever samples they could from
the walls and floors and recording photo
and video of the specimen while
collecting any method of conventional
analysis they could manage under the
given circumstances Dr Bannon kept an
eye on the old man's face the entire
entire time refusing to look away for
one second for fear of it waking in the
absence of his gaze but to his relief
the creature did not stir and the data
collection process went smoothly in a
short period of time the team had packed
their gear and proceeded to carefully
Retreat from the inner chamber of the
cube making sure to keep their lights
pointed at the creature the entire time
once the team exited the steel-lined
cube they motioned again to the camera
and the huge heavy doors of the cube
closed back in on itself the
electromagnetic supports came back
online and the cube was suspended once
again in three-dimensional space without
any immediate contact with Solid
Surfaces the security detail began
packing up their positions as everyone
seemed to take a collective sigh of
relief that's when Dr Bannon noticed the
security camera the Red Dot on the
device had stopped blinking the camera
was off a sudden feeling of dread
entered Dr bannon's stomach as he turned
in time to see all the cameras around
the room turning off before he could
react the chamber was plunged Into
Darkness as the electricity left the
room and the immediate Darkness came a
deafening bang followed by a gust of
wind and the weight of a force strong
enough to shake the ground and knock the
researchers off their feet the power of
the electromagnetic supports were down
the cube had fallen Dr Bannon shouted to
his team to immediately exit the
facility he reached for his flashlight
in the darkness he could hear screams in
the background gunfire he managed to
illuminate the space in front of him and
saw his molecular biologist Dr Burns
scrambling to get her gear back up over
her shoulder leave it Dr Bannon cried
only to see a hand emerge from beneath
her and pull her down into a black
viscous substance that swallowed her
whole and then vanished into solid
concrete after hearing the cries to his
left he swung his flashlight just in
time to see him the old man had its hand
on the chest of a security personnel and
entered him exiting through the other
side leaving a gaping hole in between
bullets were useless as they seemed to
get trapped on Entry of his body slowly
melting into his skin
scp-106 then vanished into the floor and
appear behind another member of the
security detail grabbing him by the heel
and dragging him as he pleaded and
reached out to Dr Bannon for help
pulling him halfway into the wall and
then letting go as the creature melted
into the space between the walls leaving
behind half the poor man's body bleeding
and still squirming to get away one by
one he could hear his researchers crying
out for help before their voices were
extinguished before he could think of
what to do next the power came back on
and lights flooded into the large room
he gazed at the creature as it stood
momentarily stunned by the influx of
light the old man had got piercing
Hollow eyes in a face covered in dark
melting skin and a lipless mouth that
displayed terrible decaying teeth its
corrosive hand had a grasp on the arm of
Dr Breyer the physicist burning the skin
beneath its grip as he cried out in pain
and then without warning the creature
placed a hand on the wall of the metal
cube and disappeared into it pulling the
doctor in with him into the pocket
Dimension between the walls 48 hours
later in containment site 19 located in
the state of Buddha expunged SCP
Personnel opened the door to an
observation chamber where scp-049 is let
in wearing steel-covered hand restraints
on the other side of the glass panel Dr
Blake sat impatiently watching the
humanoid creature known as scp-049 the
plague doctor take a seat and face his
Direction Dr Blake hesitated to address
the entity that sat in front of him but
putting aside his reservations he spoke
into the microphone Blake informed
scp-049 of the recent breach that had
transpired at the scp-106 containment
site the the doctor seemed intrigued at
the news and when asked if he would
provide assistance the doctor agreed
scp-049 had exhibited abilities to
produce instances of
scp-049-2 reanimated corpses that he
alone had the ability to control by Will
in the past the plague doctor had been
allowed certain privileges to see
subjects for the doctor to experiment on
in his quest to finally cure for what he
referred to as the pestilence though
none of the researchers could pinpoint
exactly what the symptoms of this
perceived illness was or any specifics
about it at all however the supply of
subjects was halted after an incident
where scp-049 struck a Personnel member
killing him instantly with his Touch of
death an ability that ceases all bodily
function upon contact since then the
plague doctor refused to cooperate
unless he was provided with live
subjects for experimentation up to this
point he had been denied but Dr Blake
needed the plague doctor's help and
timed was not on his side Dr Blake
agreed to provide scp-049 with several
live d-class Personnel in return for his
assistance as we've come to learn time
and time again here on SCP explained the
foundation has no qualms about ridding
the lives of these ex-death row inmates
d-class are essentially the foundation's
lab rats and treating them as such is
more than worth it if dealing with an
scp-106 Containment Breach bring in the
orange jumpsuits Splendid
remarks049 the plague doctor was taken
to the secret site of scp-106's
containment facility and briefed on the
old man's ability to meld and travel
between walls floors and Solid Surfaces
as well as its ability to pull objects
into its own pocket dimension of which
there was little information about
scp-049 grew more and more intrigued by
the description of the old man upon
arriving a laboratory was prepared at
the site for scp-049 for proxy to serve
as lures to bait scp-106 the team
procured the bodies of a recent public
transportation bus wreckage that had
left 12 younger adults dead as the
plague doctor began his surgeries on
them Dr Bannon could think only of the
prior containment breach the staff
suffered many casualties to personnel
and ever since then anyone under the age
of 30 were barred entry within 20 miles
of the containment site just as Dr
Bannon began to rub his Temple to think
about how they managed to return scp-106
to his cell that day there was a yell of
excitement marvelous cried out as cp049
the plague doctor informed SCP staff
that he had finished his work and the
surgeries had been of Paramount success
the doctor had indeed produced 12
instances of
scp-049-2 as predicted the subjects were
horrid Abominations some with inverted
faces and others with added appendages
and gaping holes where limbs should be
but they were ambient and the research
staff would soon learn if they would be
enough to lure scp-106 back into
containment staring at the dimly lit
White Room crowded with malformed
ambient corpses Dr Banning couldn't help
but feel a sense of dread fill the pit
of his stomach but there was no time to
second guess with rifles and flashlights
in hand the team led the troop of
scp-049-2s out and down the concrete
hallways and into a large freight
elevator that led down to the vast
chamber that housed the inner
containment Cube that was
scp-106's home since arriving at the
facility the Drone like Dash 2s did not
speak during this trip they did not
blink they simply stared straight ahead
and acted at the behest of the plague
doctor without any verbal input the
Macabre parade arrived at the entrance
of the cube and proceeded inside Dr
Bannon informed scp-049 that the dash
twos needed to make noises of some kind
to cry out if they could anything would
work as long as it was was audible
enough the plague doctor nodded his head
and all 12 of the reanimated corpses
began to scream in terrifying Unison in
the hollow distance a roar was heard in
response it dripped from the ceiling
first a drop then many more until a
puddle formed on the ground in front of
the cube the plague doctor approaching
with Intrigue out of the floor rose up
the creature known as
scp-106 coming face to face with the
plague doctor upon seeing the creature
as cp049 was ecstatic he began to
examine scp-106 closely without fear of
bodily harm with lightning speed he
produced a vial in Pinchers from a
medicine bag of black leather he kept
under his robes and snatched a sample of
the creature's black viscous skin the
plague doctor was overjoyed this will
lead to my greatest work and the cure
for the pestilence once and for all but
the old man did not seem to acknowledge
or even enjoy the presence of SC p049
and reacted violently lashing out to
strike the plague doctor sensing danger
049 jumped back and willed the 049-2s to
attack the creature but before they
could reach it as cp106 melted into a
pool of black and disappeared into the
floor the instances looked around dazed
another black pool appeared under one of
them causing it to fall into the portal
and then out from the ceiling elsewhere
in the vast stadium-sized room another
Pool opened up under one of the ambient
thralls sucking it down into the black
abyss and then another and another and
soon loud thuds could be heard echoing
through the chamber as bodies began to
appear from the top of The Hundred-Foot
ceiling falling to a splatter on the
concrete floor below upon witnessing
scp-106's abilities first hand
scp-049 nodded to Dr Bannon as he
swiftly packed up his medicine bag and
made for the door only to be blocked by
a cp106 materializing form the plague
doctor grew angry and struck the neck of
the old man with his cold Touch of death
but it seemed to have no effect on
scp-106 the black substance on his body
started to creep over 049's hand
sizzling and Searing skin and flesh as
it went up the forearm sensing danger
the plague doctor pulled out a large
scalpel and in one quick motion sliced
off his own arm at the elbow the severed
limb fell to the floor engulfed by the
black bubbling substance
scp-106 then lunged at the doctor whose
quick agility allowed him to dodge and
make for the doorway once in the hall
scp-049 quickly pulled out a roll of
brown gauze from his medical bag and
began to wrap his bleeding wound tight
as he hurried through the dimly lit
Corridor lights flickering on and off as
scp-049 turned a corner a black
substance appeared on the wall in front
of him and a chair came flying out of it
towards his head the doctor dodged it
but did not Dodge sharp metal Spike that
materialized from another hole appearing
on the wall to his left it pierced the
outside of his knee causing his movement
to be slowed hearing the sound of
clanking metal the doctor looked up in
time to see a desk falling out of
another dimensional portal above him he
managed to roll sideways missing the
blow but straight into another one of
scp-016's portals causing the doctor to
fall through the wall and into the floor
of the room below with a falling crash
the doctor landed in the lower room and
looked around quickly seeking to regain
his footing the old man was nowhere to
be seen but he could hear him bumping in
the darkness traveling through the walls
of the building the plague doctor
quickly analyzed the office room for
something useful on the wall he found a
map of the facility and studied the
schematics on the floor was a dead body
he crouched down close to it and stabbed
it with a syringe from his cloak
animating the corpse and commanding it
to run serving as a distraction to lead
scp-1000 six away so he could make it to
the adjoining hallway just a few hundred
feet away that was the Armory limping
from his injured leg the plague doctor
waited for the old man to be led away as
he made it to the room he began tearing
through the Weaponry that lined and
leaned up against the walls in every
direction ignoring the automatic rifles
as they were useless there he found what
he had been searching for flash grenades
as the form of another black portal
began to materialize in front of him he
pulled the pin and tossed the grenade in
that putrid puddle a blast of light
erupted from within followed by the
sound of the creature recoiling in pain
the plague doctor pulled another pin and
another and in this manner he led
scp-106 toward the secondary containment
facilities that had begun filling with
fluid when he reached a level where he
could recognize the smell of kerosene he
stopped there he waited as scp-106
emerged from the darkness in front of
him it's snarled and howled spitting
black bits of tar as its gnarled yellow
teeth came close to the plague doctor's
face the play doctor calmly turned and
waited out of the half-filled room
scp-106 tried to Lunge at him to follow
but it could not it found itself rooted
in liquid unable to easily open a portal
in the space between the walls stepping
out of the room the plague doctor
reached into his cloak and pulled out a
large match from his leather bag without
glancing back he struck the match and
gave a ginger toss into the Flames
sliding the door closed behind him the
resulting explosion and subsequent
Inferno damaged the walls of the
secondary containment facility and
caused significant seismic activity
within the outer walls of the
containment site emergency lights
flickered on and off in the darkness and
debris rained down from the ceiling in
every direction in this Haze of rubble
the plague doctor picked himself up off
the ground and began to dust his cloak
clean with the one hand he had left
satisfied he took a Content sigh and
began to make for the exit to the
outside world where he would resume his
quest to to rid the Earth of the
pestilence that had plagued mankind
though an unexpected surprise made him
pause a flaming corpse began to emerge
from a black hole in the wall beside him
scp-106 intact and whole the Flames
slowly seeping into his skin until they
were all extinguished and only smoke
Rose from his body this time the doctor
was not so fast to react the creature
grabbed him by the face and slammed it
into the nearby wall cracking the marble
surface the black substance pulled
around the plague doctor's face
scp-106 opened a portal in the wall
pushing the doctor's head into it the
events that followed afterwards are
difficult to put together as camera
footage from the facility suffered
severe damage due to scp-049's explosion
of the secondary containment Chambers
scp-106 was found back inside his cell
in the containment Cube back to his
dormant state where he would remain
again for the next few months that is
until he would feel the need to hunt
prey once again as the doors of the
40-layer steel Cube closed the
electromagnetic supports came back
online and the fluid Chambers repaired
and refilled the committee is currently
voting on whether or not to allow as
cp106's containment facility to be
opened again for now the world could
rest once more Dr Bannon could take a
sigh of relief but for how long he
thought for that there was no way to
tell some anomalies kill for fun others
for food others because they simply have
no choice on the other side of the coin
some want nothing more than to spread
love joy and happiness but it's rare
that you see an anomaly that has
genuinely pure intentions but his
attempts to do good often turn deadly
one such figure and the subject of
today's tale is
scp-049 the plague doctor if you're at
all familiar with the SCP Foundation
then you will have likely heard of the
infamous plague doctor for those of you
who haven't here's a bit of context for
scp-049 he appears exactly as you'd
expect a plague doctor from the late
medieval period or Renaissance periods a
tall figure shrouded in Long Black robes
a hood over his head with only a
Venetian beaked mask protruding from
underneath these aren't just a fashion
statement either the SCP Foundation
discovered that these are all part of
scp-049's physical body sharing a
similar structure to muscle and bone the
plague doctor's primary goal is to find
those he considers to be infected with
something he refers to as the pestilence
if he ever senses this Affliction he
will attempt to make direct skin contact
with the person carrying it why because
scp-049's touch is lethal killing anyone
he comes into contact with you might
think that's all the plague doctor does
goes from person to person killing them
with his deadly touch but you would be
wrong once he he's killed the victim
scp-049 then begins performing a crude
outdated form of surgery on their corpse
using equipment he produces from his
mysterious and apparently bottomless
magical medical Satchel he injects a
number of unknown chemicals into the
corpse which brings them back to life
and turns them into an instance of
scp-049-2 or in other words a vicious
mindless zombie at present scp-049 is
kept secure in a holding cell by the
foundation under watch by surveillance
cameras for 24 hours a day and that is
where our Story begins the tale of a
deadly dangerous doctor and his days
spent in captivity locked away in a cage
contained by the SCP Foundation there he
sits alone it is a tale known only by
this simple title going home it begins
with the plague doctor left alone in his
cell he had been there for such a long
time that he'd forgotten exactly how
long but there he sat taunted by the
sensation of pestilence around him it
was a small almost undetectable feeling
but it reeked of Decay and disease
hanging in the very air particles of
scp-049 cell although they have long
since stopped the practice the SCP
Foundation used to send its doctors and
researchers into 049's cell bringing him
cadavers as test subjects the plague
doctor would use these specimens to hone
his craft perfecting his method of
transforming the dead into instances of
scp-049-2 but of course the doctors
working for the foundation weren't
exactly free of disease themselves and
they too often needed to be cured by his
touch and soon they stopped visiting
scp-049 in person leaving him alone in
his cell even these so-called people of
science feared the true cure it seemed
they would talk to the plague doctor via
an intercom system interviewing him and
asking questions about what he did or
how he felt one question stood out to
scp-049 the foundation researchers have
asked him if he had any regrets for what
he had done to people the plague doctor
thought it foolish to even ask and then
even the questions coming through the
intercom stopped after a while for a
time as cp049 was happy in his cell left
alone with his thoughts safe from the
diseases of the outside world the black
doctor was at peace for a change resting
in Comfort until the familiar smell of
pestilence returned the presence of
disease drove him to attempt an escape
producing his medical implements from
his bag he kept concealed in his robes
scp-049 tried to pry open the door to
his cell he wasn't sure how long it took
the passage of time had long since
stopped registering to him but
eventually he had it open just enough so
that he could pass through out into the
corridor beyond the chamber that he had
been held in there was no one else
around no doctors or researchers or
Foundation security Personnel no one to
stop the plague doctor from following
the stench of the disease that had
driven him to find a way out of
containment navigating through the
hallways of the foundation facility
scp-049 tracked the source of the
disease to a locker with little trouble
he opened it finding a metallic box
within as he studied the container his
fingers found the button that opened it
it hissed as the gases kept the inside
of the Box mixed with the air the cold
Vapor hit the plague doctor in the face
catching him by surprise and making him
drop the Box reasserting himself the
blade doctor bent over and picked up the
contents of the refrigerated container a
single mosquito it wasn't the insect
itself that hadron scp-049 out of his
cell true mosquitoes are known to spread
diseases like malaria but it was what
was inside this mosquito that the doctor
wanted to eradicate its blood sack was
full swollen with dark fluid that
scp-049 knew to be infected using the
metal box is an improvised operating
table he produced his bag of medical
implements and the doctor began to
operate he retrieved a syringe from his
bag and a vial filled with thick black
liquid half filling the syringe with the
liquid he plunged the needle into the
mosquito and extracted the blood that
the insect was carrying the infected
bodily fluid mixed with the medicine in
the doctor's syringe leaving the bug is
little more than a dry husk the plague
doctor watched as the two substances
mixed together before stabbing back into
the mosquito filling the creature with a
combination of both liquids he refused
to leave any trace of pestilence in the
insect's body the mosquito twitched
itself back to life looking around until
it saw scp-049 observing it who's there
it asked where's merley there is no one
here but me and you the doctor explained
you are in a prison though the wardens
eats scenes have lived a prison the
insect responded oh God I'm at site 19.
naturally it seemed rather strange for a
mosquito to be able to talk let alone
know about the highly classified site-19
but as is always the case in the SCP
Foundation the strange always has an
anomalous explanation you see this
mosquito was not like any other for one
she even had a name it was Leslie as it
turned out Leslie was part of an SCP one
of the foundation's own creation
scp-3774 these were a genetically and
cybernetically enhanced species of
mosquito why would the foundation spend
time and resources creating something
like this originally they were designed
as an undetectable covert way of keeping
tabs on Persons of Interest to the SCP
Foundation the plague doctor thought it
odd that after having spent so much time
in prison there that he should finally
learn the name of site 19 from a
mosquito of all things let's seemed to
be in a state of panic however urgently
insisting that she had to get back to
someone named merley
scp-049 had no clue what she meant he'd
never encountered anyone that went by
that name and had no idea where to even
begin looking I know where he lives I
can find it the mosquito insisted I just
I don't know how I could ever get out of
here she was wary of the creature she
found herself talking to despite being a
genetically engineered insect Leslie was
for all intents and purposes an agent of
the SCP Foundation and now she was
currently conversing with an anomaly
that she knew nothing about but he
wasn't trying to harm her in fact
whatever the plague doctor had done
seemed to have revived her I have gotten
myself this far and now that I have I
have no further reason to stay here the
doctor announced holding a handout for
Leslie to fly up to then then you'll
help me get out of here she asked
readying her wings and landing in his
palm I will
scp-049 agree the pair introduced
themselves properly Leslie giving
scp-049 her name while he just
instructed her to call him doctor before
they set out together after almost a
week of traveling on foot through rugged
terrain and harsh winds the plague
doctor and his insect companion had yet
to encounter another living Soul thick
dark clouds hung in the sky above them
and Leslie soon found it hard to
remember what the sun looked like she
feared that she might even forget
merly's face we're close she said just a
few more miles and then and then we will
arrive as cp049 finished her sentence
tell me doctor why did you come all this
way with me Leslie the mosquito asked
you could have left when we got out gone
on your own way in response he gave one
simple sentence merely because I wanted
to finally the Intrepid pair arrived at
a house once belonging to Merle it was
abandoned ramshackle in a total state of
disrepair decades had passed since
anyone had set foot in the place the
living room that had once been so
familiar to Leslie had now been
transformed into a Barren empty space
the sight of it made her so distraught
with sadness that she would have been
sick if mosquitoes could be sick Merle
whoever he was or had been was now
nowhere to be found one of Leslie's
cybernetic enhancements was an internal
positioning system giving her all sorts
of data and readouts including a clock
it told her just how long she'd been
away for I've been dead for 200 years
the mosquito cried in the palm of the
doctor's hand then the merlis is dead
everyone everyone is dead she kept
repeating it to herself over and over as
if she was trying to convince herself of
what had happened eventually the words
lost all meaning as he held Leslie in
his hands perhaps the plague doctor felt
sorry for the mosquito after all the
plague doctor had always had a
respectful polite personality despite
his frightening exterior he had always
believed that he'd acted in service of
the greater good trying to cure the
world of pestilence to bring the end of
disease he only ever killed because to
him it was in his victim's best interest
for him to perform his procedures to his
captors at the SCP Foundation the doctor
had been courteous and cooperative and
he acted the same towards his fellow
scps not just Leslie but even the sort
of anomalies with nothing but hatred in
their hearts the doctor saw them as just
further victims of the pestilence in
need of curing
scp-049 sat in silence for a while with
his mosquito friend letting her mourn
the loss of Merle and everything she had
ever known where will you go now he
asked still in tears barely able to
speak through her sobs Leslie decided
that she wanted to stay where she was
the insect wanted to live where Merle
had lived in a desperate attempt to
recapture the world that she once knew
sitting in the plague doctor's gloved
hands still sobbing even though she had
run out of Tears Leslie said any minute
any minute Merle will come through the
door the plague doctor held his tiny
companion where she was while she
grieved then I would wait for him he
told her here with you
scp-049 is a fascinating bundle of
contradictions arguably he's the
Hannibal Lecter of the anomalous World
he's educated refined and cultured a
scientific man with scientific goals
capable of communicating eloquently in
both English and medieval French as
anomalies go he's one of the more
Cooperative ones contained by the SCP
Foundation willing to understand reason
and even showing a small degree of
respect for his fellow researchers and
yet despite all this intelligence and
refinement underneath his dark organic
cloak a heart of deep red violence
steadily beats he's capable of ending
life with a mere touch causing all
biological function in the body to
Simply cease through means that are
still unknown to science thanks to a
series of inconclusive autopsies on
scp-049's unaltered victims not only is
killing easy in a physical sense for
scp-049 with a few notable exceptions
it's also been just as easy on his
conscience such is the danger of the Man
or Monster who believes unshakably that
his goals are righteous any moral crime
is permissible if done in service of
seeing them through and for those who
die at scp-049's hand an even greater
indignity awaits his inhuman experiments
the gateway to a second life as an
abominable crime against nature a glob
of malignant spit in the eye of God but
let's not get too ahead of ourselves
here students we've mentioned scp-049
countless times in passing before some
of his Strange Tales his interact
actions with other anomalies like
scp-682 and even with some of your
questions and theories about this bone
masked scientific madman and yet he
still remains a mystery perhaps to truly
understand this fascinating walking
question we need to return to the
beginning and give the classified files
behind the plague doctor a closer look
like many of the infamous anomalies
discovered by the SCP Foundation the
files indicate that the discovery itself
was first triggered by a series of
mysterious disappearances in the Sleepy
town of montabon out in southern France
people across races classes ages and
genders were simply falling off the map
suggesting a highly indiscriminate
assailant little did the foundation know
in the BD avian eyes of their killer
they all had an extremely important
commonality each and every one of them
was infected with the pestilence the
invisible Scourge the Great dying their
killer was the only one with the proper
diagnostic mind to even notice the
infection he was the only one who could
save the world from this Insidious
unseen threat and then the SCP
Foundation discovered his laboratory the
plague doctor had been doing his
delicate work in an abandoned house on
the edge of town the kind of place that
gets whispered about in local rumors a
bad place a cursed Place little did they
know it was only the latest in a long
line of covert research centers for this
singularly inspired Medicine Man while
some of the details were a little foggy
in his memory he'd been carrying out his
work for a little over 400 years now
moving from place to place causing
strings of disappearances wherever he
showed up in his own words he's an
extremely well-traveled man and still
the cure for the Blasted pestilence
continued to evade him he sat in that
decrepit montabon house surrounded by by
groaning writhing Abominations of his
own creation taking meticulous notes
nothing would break his concentration
not even the strangers in the Black
Tactical Gear with large guns kicking in
his front doors his many cured patients
didn't take kindly to the intrusion on
their treatment and decided to swarm The
Interlopers What followed was a violent
struggle between The Intruders and the
cured resulting in several of The
Intruders injured and all of the Cure
dead once more during all this chaos the
plague doctor never once stopped taking
notes when he was finished with his
sentence he willingly submitted to
capture by this mysterious SCP
Foundation after all when he told them
about the true nature of his mission
they would of course see reason and
allow him to continue his research sure
he may have committed a few crimes
against nature on the way but he was
working in service of loftier ideals you
can only imagine his profound relief
when he was first interviewed by SCP
Foundation researcher Dr Raymond Hamm in
site 85 he was in the presence of fellow
Scholars people of science he worried at
first that he'd been captured by some
group of Common Street Scoundrels when
in fact the hands of Providence had
delivered him into the perfect place to
continue his research the warm light of
Fate was now smiling on him after so
long languishing in the dark all he
needed to do was allow the scientists
around him to conduct tests on his own
body while he conducted tests on others
at first the SCP Foundation believed he
was an anomalous human being wearing a
costume but they soon discovered that he
was something very different what they
thought was a mask was actually an
outgrowth of his skull a kind of
insect-like exoskeleton the robes were
also a component of his body a kind of
thick hide that developed over the years
the thickness of the Hide itself also
made him impervious to a great deal of
physical damage despite his politeness
research notes on the plague doctor
indicated that Foundation Personnel
found interacting with him uncanny there
was an oddly Eerie quality to him
something indistinguishable that just
felt off the foundation also found that
the plague doctor whom they initially
addressed as Doctor rather than scp-049
out of a sense of mutual respect also
came with a number of strange personal
effects these included a long pointing
stick similar to the ones used by
medieval plague doctors to touch things
without fear of contamination this stick
was soon confiscated it didn't possess
any anomalous qualities but the plague
doctor had a tendency to gesture
grantedly with it as he spoke and the
foundation feared he absent-mindedly
take someone's eye out with it if he
wasn't careful the other two personal
effects that the plague doctor prize
greatly was his old-fashioned medical
bag and the notebook that he obsessively
recorded his observations with the
medical bag would which seemed to
exhibit anomalous properties contained a
mix of archaic medical tools as well as
some that the foundation has been unable
to identify it's through the tools in
this bag that the plague doctor is able
to create instances of
scp-049-2 as we alluded to earlier the
plague doctor can kill with a touch but
that's only part of what he does to his
victims after causing all their
biological functions to cease he takes
the tools out of his medical bag and
begins performing crude surgery on their
corpse including using a syringe to
inject an unknown anomalous liquid into
their flesh while the specifics on the
plague doctor's modifications can vary
from victim to victim the result is
often the same they're converted into
strange shambling Abominations that
aren't capable of any kind of higher
thought for the most part their
movements are extremely basic and
limited however if they're provoked they
can become frighteningly violent more
than capable of killing an armed
Foundation guard if they don't remain
alert during the engagement the SCP
Foundation was given a unique
opportunity to understand more about
scp-049's Twisted experiments as part of
his conditions for containment they
agreed to provide the Diabolical doctor
with a number of fresh test subjects the
doctor was eager to continue his work
and through watching him work the SCP
Foundation could learn a great deal more
about him though we wouldn't even
pretend that the plague doctor's work
has ever been enjoyable to watch they
presented him with some live subjects
and a much greater number of mammalian
corpses he would spend several days
working intensely on each one then
documenting his findings in his precious
notebook as a mark of respect for the
foundation scientists around him the
plague doctor was more than eager to
share his research with them and compare
notes he was always a talkative one
perhaps just as excited to discuss his
experiments and theories with
like-minded Scholars after so many years
of working alone
here are four notable instances first
the plague doctor was presented with a
live d-class specimen he thanked the
foundation greatly for this gift then
set about his work he asked the unaware
d-class several questions about his
medical history while retrieving tools
from his bag before quickly touching and
killing the man he performed extensive
modifications on the d-class corpse and
when he was resurrected as an
scp-049-2 instance he was barely
recognizable as his original form he was
a bizarre flailing creature constantly
groaning and gasping from the
oblong-shaped hole that the plague
doctor had carved into his chest while
performing this horrifying work the
plague doctor eagerly remarked to the
observing researchers that The Cure
appears to be extremely effective next
he was provided the corpse of a recently
deceased goat which he also expressed
gratitude for after performing surgery
on the creature it was successfully
resurrected into a bizarre
scp-049-2 instance however the plague
doctor readily admitted that this
definitely wasn't his best work
commenting the disease was still in its
nascent stage my Veterinary practice is
rudimentary but the Patient responded
well to the procedure next he was
provided the corpse of a recently
deceased orangutan the plague doctor was
delighted by this commenting that given
primate similarities to human physiology
this would be the next best thing from a
true human test subject however this
research became surprisingly fraught he
killed and reanimated the Beast four
different times seemingly unsatisfied
with the result each time and when he
failed to reanimate the creature a fifth
time he seemed disconcerted in a
debriefing discussion the plague doctor
said I have learned so much from this
though I fear my early optimism was
misplaced I hadn't yet come across such
a a stumbling block on my road to the
Cure more subjects like this would do a
great deal in advancing my research next
we was provided with the corpse of a
recently deceased cow this irritated
scp-049 who wanted test subjects who
were physiologically closer to humans
still despite his frustration he
continued to work he took only brief
breaks to enjoy a meal of hard cheese
salted pork and thin crackers Tess
showed that scp-049 didn't require
sustenance to survive but he enjoyed the
act of eating and found that it helped
him with his work he embalmed the cow
rearranging its organs and even inverted
its head however this didn't impede his
work he injected it with a variety of
liquids which he described as the
essence of the humors when asked to
elaborate further on this he said the
pestilence may bring about a systemic
imbalance in such a case before true
healing can begin one must find the
humerus in balance or the body will
reject the Cure this is of course
Elementary knowledge for the Practical
physician I would have thought to have
learned this during your education after
being provided a working cattle Rod to
induce a little electricity into the
equation the plague doctor successfully
reanimated the mutant cow from here
things started to go downhill Dr Ham
decided to conduct another interview
with scp-049 hoping to get into the
finer details of his scientific process
however they hit some major roadblocks
scp-049 seemed to be unable to actually
articulate the true nature of the
pestilence or his process in seeking The
Cure even his notebook wasn't written in
any known language and proved impossible
to decipher as the interview went on the
plague doctor seemed to become
increasingly distressed insisting on the
importance of his work to helping the
human race prosper and survive this
terrible plague all he needed in
exchange was more test subjects the
practice civility that had been built up
between the plague doctor and the SCP
Foundation crumbled in 2017. after a
tragic incident in the plague doctor
cell with Dr Ham when he entered to
perform a very standard interview with
the plague doctor the doctor appeared to
become anxious and asked Dr Ham if he
was feeling well today Dr Ham thought
nothing of it and tried to continue the
interview but by that point it was
already too late the plague doctor had
come to believe that Dr Ham was infected
with the pestilence and of course there
was only one cure the plague doctor gave
Dr Ham his Touch of death the man died
instantly and the plague doctor
immediately went about turning his
corpse into another
scp-049-2 instance because ham was
killed so quickly he didn't have time to
activate his emergency security signal
meaning what was left of him wasn't
discovered until three hours later
guards and researchers were horrified to
see one of their own turned into a
Mindless deformed Monster by an anomaly
they all thought they could trust
following this tragic incident Dr Theron
Sherman chastised the plague doctor for
this appalling breach of trust and the
cold-blooded murder of Dr Raymond Ham
the plague doctor in a state of
increasing distressed insisted that ham
was infected and he did all that he
could to cure him and while the plague
doctor insisted a certain level of
scientific distance from his subject it
seemed that deep down he regretted the
loss of a friend and fellow researcher
in his Endless Quest against the
pestilence after this incident the
plague doctor truly became as cp049 he
lost all of his privileges and now
remains under lock and key in sight 19.
whenever he's transported he's kept in
shackles and supervised by a number of
armed guards after discovering that the
scent of lavender has a pacifying effect
on him it's regularly used as a
tranquilizer against him during
engagements this is how a cordial Ally
can become just another prisoner in the
eyes of the SCP Foundation in a summary
interview after the Dr Ham incident Dr
Elijah itkin asked if 049 had any
regrets about the incident noting that
he seemed oddly mournful 049 pause
before replying Moon perhaps I had not
thought that it is lamentable that a
fellow doctor became infected but the
work continues regrettable as as it was
Dr Ham's death provided important
Insight living human subjects are the
only way to proceed forward time decided
my curies of little use on dead flesh
and I have cleaned all I can from your
generous supply of corpses my desires
turned towards tending to those still
living who suffer from the disease Dr
itkin replied that 049 would be
disappointed on that front he just
laughed in response and replied
oh doctor I wouldn't be so sure a world
that's lost its way needs a Healer
someone to patch up its wounds and tend
to its pain it needs a doctor when day
broke the sun turned from a Giver of
Life the thing that wakes the rooster
and makes the crops grow to an
indiscriminate killer wiping out all
organic life forms the world seemed
truly lost but one anomalous being made
it his goal to soothe the hurt to make
it safe to step into the light once more
the plague doctor had done his best with
the limited resources afforded to him at
the abandoned Foundation site the
scientists had left behind all of their
equipment when the Red Sun came when
they all were transformed he had
appointed himself the site director
willing to take up the mantle when no
one else would he had assembled the
brave brilliant team of fellow anomalies
the verbose Dr spenko the eloquent
Adventure interest Lord Blackwood and
the charismatic but ravenous Ferdinand
there had of course been those who
scoffed at his vision who did not share
his Noble goal the Abominable possessive
mask taunted him persistently trying its
best to get under his chitinous skin but
he did not have time to waste on Such
trivial psychological games and he
ignored its taunts to focus on the work
it hadn't been easy capturing one of the
infected specimens the former human
being turned mass of oozing gelatinous
flesh by the Unholy light in the sky one
had made its way into the abandoned
facility sliding its way across the
floor with an air of confused malice it
wanted to hurt but it didn't know where
it was who it was anymore but it was
frightened the blade doctor could tell a
good physician always knows and can
sense the fear and pain of a suffering
person it made his heart ache to see and
he knew there was only one thing to do
try to make this poor soul well again
everyone please assist me in escorting
the patient to my laboratory the doctor
called out this was once a man and I
believe without a combined intellect and
resources we can return him to his
former State Ferdinand took a step
toward the slimy creature licking his
lips a bit do you think I could have
just a little bit of it oh I'm so hungry
doctor he begged no no it would go
against my oath as a physician to allow
any more harm to come to this poor
fellow the plague doctor shook his head
solemnly Fernand pouted but did not
press the issue further no the doctor
rubbed his gloved hands together in
anticipation of the next task it is
imperative we contain our new friends
safely if you would please he gestured
to several of his previous patients now
reanimated and ready to Aid him with his
research the shuffling figure surrounded
the Blobby and City ushering it down the
hall confused lost with no real sense of
a plan left in its mushy Consciousness
the creature followed where it was led
the group made it back to the doctor's
laboratory shouted Dr spenko from his
Purge atop a nearby shelf yes indeed the
doctor replied he standard operating
table was in due for such a special
patient I have nowhere to place the
restraints you see I will have to make
do with the floor further than my bag if
you please the giant rushed to his side
dropping the bag at his feet if he dies
then can I eat it he asked shifting from
one foot to the other like a child
asking a parent for a second helping of
ice cream if I am unable to save the
patient which I do deem unlikely then
yes you may help me dispose of The
Remains the doctor relented but I do not
hope it comes to that he pressed a hand
to his beak in deep thought for a moment
before opening his bag and pulling out a
syringe filled with clear liquid to
begin we must sedate the patient yet no
way to find the veins and so he plunged
the needle into the nearest section of
the creature's soft surface injecting a
dose of sedative then he waited the
using motion of the entity slowed and
stopped it laid there on the ground a
still mound of Flesh save for the
occasional expanding and Contracting
motion almost as if it was breathing
excellent now there was no risk of the
patient fleeing the operating room
mid-procedure he could truly begin it
was an arduous process that took hours
of effort of taking small tissue samples
attempting to make incisions only for
the flesh to fuse back together seconds
after the scalpel was taken away this
was truly an advanced illness unlike
anything he had ever seen before it was
enough to make him question his
abilities as a doctor but he shook the
thought away self-pity never helped
anyone after about eight hours of
continuous work he had a breakthrough a
solution he had created long ago a thick
green liquid sealed in a Dusty jar had a
miraculous effect when dripped onto one
of the tissue samples the melted flesh
reconstituted became solid and human
again Eureka he cried out unable to
restrain the sudden joy that leaped into
his heart this could be it very
carefully he filled the dropper with the
green liquid if these initial trials had
been successful then perhaps he couldn't
finish the thought best not to get ahead
of himself he crossed to his patients
and slowly began to pour the solution
over the creature's viscous surface he
watched as the flesh toughened coming
together into a surface resembling human
skin it was working it was working but
then the creature began to quiver
shaking uncontrollably like a bowl of
jelly in an earthquake the surface
rippled and the doctor could hear a
high-pitched wine filling the room then
with a wet pop the patient exploded
sending chunks of Flesh splattering all
over the room painting the walls and
ceiling the doctor cried out in shock
and horror and in spite of himself fell
to his knees in despair he had been so
close but still he had failed and who
could say when he would find another
test subject if he would ever find a
cure I'm afraid I do not know what to do
now the doctor admitted fernand's side
the next several days passed in a haze
the doctor paced around his laboratory
mulling over his possible mistakes again
and again he had rushed the process he
was certain of that now it was a novice
mistake the sort of thing he might have
done a century or two ago how could he
have been so foolish how could he have
made that innocent pay the price for his
own hubris as the doctor locked himself
away in his mind Palace Fernand occupied
himself by practicing his favorite songs
Lord Blackwood wrote on the massive
man's shoulder as he sang through the
Opera Don Giovanni I everyone saw a
production of this at the Teatro La
Venice in Venice Lord Blackwood
interjected his Rhino poor is twitching
in delight at the memory marvelous
production marvelous City I was there
hunting a rogue tattoo of wrecking Havoc
through the canals I nearly lost my life
on that voyage
would all be quiet for once in your
miserable lives a voice hissed from the
Shadows there on the doorway its face
fixed in the frown was the possessive
mask black slime dripped from its eye
holes spilling down onto the plastic
mannequin body it had taken hold of
listening to you both is worse than
being locked in that infernal box The
Mask looked around the room searching
for someone
where is the good doctor it asked voice
dripping with disdain
still moping about counting its failures
ignore him my fine fellow Lord Blackwood
whispered to Fernand only those with
weak constitutions and no achievements
of their own spend their days dragging
others down when you have lived as long
as I you will learn this
[Laughter]
careful my Lord I'll stop by the kitchen
and find some salt to pour on you if you
wish to fight me then challenge me to a
fair duel like a man the colorful slug
bellowed drawn by the sun shouting the
doctor walked into the room what is all
this commotion
oh good the mass clapped its plastic
hands together its face warping back
into an eerie smile
there you are this has all been so
dreadfully boring I came to see the
remnants of your greatest shame are
there still blood stains on the floor in
your pathetic little laboratory you are
a villain the doctor sieved
uncomfortable with the air of conflict
in the room Fernand and Lord Blackwood
quickly exited to find another space
where they could sing and share stories
and peace
I simply speak the truths no one wants
to hear the mass crossed to the doctor's
side with a series of light dance-like
steps that made the mannequin body creak
in fact I have quite a few truths to
share today I've been outside you see
whatever's become of the Sun or the
effects organic beings and so he
gestured from his ceramic face to his
plastic body
I am quite safe from its rays you've
been outside the doctor couldn't keep
the Curiosity out of his voice he was a
scientist after all my years would you
like to know what I've seen
black slime drip from the mask's mouth
pooling on the floor with a sizzling
sound I'm in no mood for tricks the
doctor warned the mask held up his hands
and mocked surrender no tricks doctor
but if you'd rather take your chances
outside and see for yourself I can take
my leave now no the doctor shook his
head please do tell me
it's so much worse than you could even
imagine the mask's words were Bleak but
its tone was gleeful
everywhere you look up there the light
has made monsters humans dogs cats mice
the wild beasts of the forest all melted
down into creatures you would not even
recognize
that isn't all no that is not
there are massive beasts Ten Feet Tall
or more laid from dozens and dozens of
the creatures coming together they fuse
and meld into one giant entity roving
the streets in search of more and more
bodies to add to the pile and ooze a
gaping mob hunger and hate that seeks
only to consume and destroy
calls out to surviving humans in the
voices of their fallen loved ones thugs
of their heartstrings to lure them out
of their hiding places and then it wraps
around them with fleshy tentacles
pulling them in until they are no more
just another part of the monster oh
doctor it's Terror it's an Abomination
I could watch it all day
the doctor wanted to believe the mask
was lying that it was trying to torment
with him with awful Fabrications but
after all he had seen so far he knew
that its words were true get out of my
sight he said or what the mask stared
him down with its unmoving smile I've
seen what you do to your hosts you know
your body won't last forever the doctor
growled hmm true maybe next I'll take
yours
hahaha The Mask laughed a long dark
laugh of something ancient and evil then
it turned and walked out the door
leaving the doctor alone he spent so
much of his time that way lately his
assistants were preoccupied his former
patients provided no real company and so
he did what he did best carry on in
solitude he couldn't be sure how long he
stood there in silence thinking of what
the mask told him he knew it was
dangerous outside knew he was up against
powerful destructive forces but it was
even worse than he had thought what if
the world was truly doomed what if this
was how it all ended not with a bang but
with the great melting suddenly the
doctor heard a sound he hadn't heard
since the sun turned wrong a scream a
human scream could it be he had to see
for himself he grabbed his bag of tools
and rushed down the hall his robes
fluttering behind him there was again a
different human voice screaming in
Terror as he grew closer to the sound he
could hear footsteps various other
voices overlapping with each other he
rounded the corner and there they were a
group of five humans wrapped in tattered
clothes dirty and exhausted behind them
was the entrance to what looked like a
tunnel somehow they found a secret
passage in mathered way inside then he
saw what made them scream clearly these
people were afraid and unaccustomed to
the sight of a man of fernand's stature
especially when the man was drooling and
staring at them with hunger in his eyes
he would have to Defuse The Situation
quickly hello welcome we mean you know
no harm strangers he stepped between
Fernand and the humans the man at the
front of the group brandished a firearm
pointing the barrel directly at the
doctor's beak please sir there is no
need for violence what are you the man
stammered the other members of his party
cowered behind him an ally if you will
permit me to be I'm a physician you see
working on a cure for the condition that
breaks the world with the shaking hand
the man slowly lowered his gun son he
did not put it away though you've
figured out a cure for those things I am
in the process of developing it so far I
have not been successful but perhaps
with your help how do we know we can
trust you the man demanded how am I
supposed to know you're not part of this
do you know who this man is Fernando
this is Dr John Watson and I am
detective Sherlock Holmes the greatest
investigator in the world that isn't the
case we can solve the man looked at the
woman next to him and the two shared a
wide-eye glance this this guy's crazy he
whispered furtively put your weapon away
and we can speak more calmly the doctor
proposed at this inopportune moment a
few of his revived patients shambled
into view the man screamed again this
time he fired his weapon shooting at one
of the walking corpses the bullets
ricocheted off the walls and several of
the patients were hit please stop
stop no other option the doctor grabbed
the man's arm hoping to get a hold of
the weapon and end the potential
Bloodshed as soon as his gloved handmade
contact the man went limp and dropped to
the ground with a hard thud the woman
next to him pulled him into her arms
checking his pulse he's dead she
shrieked tears streaming down her face I
I am so sorry my lady I did not intend
she grabbed the man's gun and trained it
on the doctor once more you killed him
she cried the other survivors were too
shaken to speak to move one of them had
his back turned to the group and was
staring into the darkness behind him
whatever he was looking at it was worse
than the chaos unfolding but no one
noticed the beige flesh tentacle snaking
along the ground until it was too late
until it had grabbed a hold of the man's
ankle and dragged him into the tunnel
with a shriek of pure unadulterated
Terror the woman nearly dropped her gun
at the sound whirling around to see what
had happened deep in the tunnel the
screen warped into a wet gurgling sound
and then there was silent for a long
moment but then something worse a gooey
slimy sound the sound of something
enormous something soft and fleshy
making its way through the tunnel and
toward the group another tentacle curled
around the edge of the opening then
another joined it something emerged that
might have once been a hand but had
melted into something unrecognizable the
monster emerged piece by piece until the
doctor could see the entire thing it
looked like a heap of people dozens of
them clambering on top of each other
wrapping their limbs together until
their flesh and insides emptied out and
fused into a shapeless mass and moved a
bit like a giant slug slimy and slow but
it seemed to know it could take its time
as the Survivor scrambled back away from
it Fernand and the doctor taking a few
steps back of their own the sound of
human voices filled the room there were
unintelligible Whispers the soft giggle
of a child a woman weeping come and be
with us the little boys boys broke
through the cacophony Mommy I miss you
don't you miss me the woman with a gun
let out a broken SOB Billy she sniffled
it's me mommy the innocent voice
continued emanating from somewhere deep
inside the Monstrous mass that crept
along the ground swelling and grasping
with its ropey tentacles come play with
me outside all you have to do is come
outside but then the creature is not
what claims to be the doctor spoke up
and it seemed to shake the woman out of
a trance you're not my son she hissed
squeezing the trigger and firing at the
monster the bullet made contact with a
wet useless slap and disappeared into
the roving pile of the Fallen she fired
again and again but the monster did not
stop it did not even slow down it lashed
out with a tentacle that wrapped around
her throat in a single fluid motion and
snapped her neck with a crack she fell
to the ground and the tentacle pulled
her into its depths until she was no
longer visible she hadn't been taken by
the Sun
yet but she was still lost the rest of
the survivors followed their screamed
silence one by one the doctor felt the
same overwhelming sense of hopelessness
wash over him the same shadow that had
passed over him when he lost the last
patient what could he do he was one
physician against an overpowering force
of Destruction perhaps he could touch it
and would fall dead like so many other
organisms before but what if it didn't
What If instead it wrapped around his
body and squeezed the life from him what
if it carried him out into that cursed
sunlight and he melted away like the
others he had to make a decision because
the Beast was advancing toward him
doctor fernan shouted he's going to
destroy our facility indeed the creature
was flailing its appendages around
beating against the walls and trying to
tear down steel and plaster break down
the shelter until they too were exposed
to the deadly light I'm afraid this may
be the end my friend
the doctor lamented I can see no hope
for us now no Ferdinand shook his head
let me save us let me lead it back
outside you'll be taken the doctor cried
perhaps not I am a magnificent specimen
after all I believe I can withstand the
Sun and return to continue our work
together Fernand scooped his sleeping
Lord Blackwood from his shoulder and
placed him gingerly on a nearby shelf
thank you for your company then he
turned back to the doctor and thank you
for my freedom and your friendship it
has been an honor before the doctor
could protest Fernand was running his
thunderous steps pounding the Earth as
he led the monster in a chase it took
the bait following this new large Target
back outside he sealed off the tunnel
behind them ensuring the Beast would not
return the way it came he wanted to
believe ferdinance bravado to think that
the Behemoth of a man had survived
outside but that night he saw the great
Beast ooze past a window and he could
make out that familiar wide toothy grin
protruding from its side just like that
the greatest assistant he had ever had
was lost thank you for your service my
friend he whispered to himself I
solemnly swear to you your death shall
not be in vain now first things first
just in case you aren't yet familiar
with scp-049 otherwise known as the
infamous plague doctor then we're here
to bring you up to speed it'll help you
get the most out of today's tale
scp-049 is a tall humanoid entity always
seen wearing long black robes a hood
over its head and a beaked mask
protruding from underneath the same kind
of mask worn by physicians during the
height of the Black Death however these
parts of the plague doctor's attire
aren't just a costume the SCP Foundation
discovered that all of scp-049's outfit
is actually part of his physical body in
other words the robes the hood The Mask
they are all made out of muscle and bone
the plague doctor's only real goal in
life is to hunt down any person it deems
to be infected The Entity often refers
to something he calls the pestilence and
upon sensing this Affliction in a human
being
scp-049 will attempt to make direct skin
contact with whoever is apparently
carrying said pestilence the plague
doctor's touch is lethal killing anyone
he comes into contact with you might
think that's as bad as it gets that this
creature just goes from person to person
killing them via touch but you would be
wrong it gets worse killing one of his
victims is only the start afterwards
scp-049 then begins performing a crude
outdated form of surgery defiling and
repurposing the person's corpse using
equipment that he produces from his
iconic doctor's bag he injects a number
of unknown chemicals into a person's
carcass eventually turning them into an
instance of of
scp-049-2 in essence a vicious
incredibly aggressive zombie the most
bizarre part in scp-049 is mine this
means he's just cured you naturally as
cp049 is already held in containment
safely Locked Away by the SCP Foundation
at present scp-049 resides in a humanoid
holding cell closely monitored by
surveillance cameras for 24 hours a day
every single day the SCP Foundation used
to send its doctors and researchers into
scp-049 cell or would make a habit of
bringing him cadavers as test subjects
fresh bodies for the plague doctor to
hone his surgical skills the researchers
would keenly observe the doctor
transforming the dead into instances of
scp-049-2 but these researchers and
doctors working for the foundation
weren't exactly free of disease meaning
every time they entered scp-049 cell
they were at risk of receiving his
deadly touch in this cage with this
deadly dangerous doctor that spends all
his time in captivity that's where our
story starts but while you might expect
a story about the plague doctor to
revolve solely around violence disease
and death this tale offers a surprising
Divergence boiled scrambled and fried is
a story about an unexpected New Life
coming into existence in a frankly
bizarre fashion all starting in that
tiny containment chamber where scp-049
had been held since the foundation first
captured him it had been increasingly
obvious to the researchers observing him
that something was quite wrong with a
plank doctor for the first time since
the doctor had arrived in the
foundation's custody he appeared to have
fallen ill unexpectedly the security
cameras that were trained on him day in
and day out recorded scp-049 groaning in
pain clutching his stomach as he limped
weakly around the confines of his cell
had the pestilence finally gotten the
better of the good doctor was he too now
infected the same as the world around
him the foundation's Medics were
confused baffled as to what could
possibly be wrong with the creature of
course it would also have been easier to
examine the doctor if they could easily
touch him without the risk of dying or
if his body wasn't made of skin robes
nonetheless the plague doctor was
brought to a medical station for a
proper diagnosis under the orders of one
Dr Richard omel a foundation Doctor Who
specialized in taking care of humanoid
anomalies and who had been assigned as
scp-049's caretaker the creature tried
to assure Dr omell that he was strong
enough to withstand the intense pain he
was obviously suffering from putting on
gloves for safety Dr omell felt a
distinct lump with an scp-049 stomach
initially believing it to be a case of
abdominal distension this is a condition
that occurs when gases or fluids build
up in the stomach and cause it to swell
up and inflate usually as a symptom of
another internal disease but scp-049
assured his caretaker that his condition
wasn't the result of any disease and in
fact it had even apparently happened
before Dr omell asked scp-049 why he had
never told the foundation about this or
why the creature wouldn't explain what
was happening I did not think you would
believe me so I said nothing
scp-049 explained doctor I am pregnant
I'm sorry but I can't explain it please
just let me return to my cell I need to
make the proper preparations naturally
this statement was met with stunned
belief by Dr omell especially seeing as
the foundation had been observing
scp-049 through security cameras for
months on end without stopping the
creature couldn't explain tensing up and
breathing heavily due to suffering
obvious and intense pain as Dr omell
rushed out to grab more members of
medical staff the plague doctor
continued struggling against the aches
letting out his loudest of cries yet as
an extreme bout of Agony sir through him
a pearly white egg gently tumbled out
from scp-049's robes just as Dr omell
and a group of foundation Medics arrived
staring in shock at what had just
happened seeming to recover quite
quickly the plague doctor asked to be
Unshackled and returned to a cell to
tend to the egg worried it would die
unless he was able to care for it as the
Shock Doctor omel agreed as cp049 gently
picked up the egg and cradled it in his
arms of course this all came as quite an
unexpected turn of events to the
foundation reports were filed and
archive entries had to be updated but
they allowed the plague doctor to keep
his egg and raise it perhaps just so
they could watch and research as it
happened instead of out of any sense of
kindness for the next five days the
creature was fixated entirely on caring
for the egg all his energy focused on it
he built a nest in the corner of his
containment cell out of fabric and paper
and would sit on the egg in order to
keep it warm during that time a number
of foundation researchers assigned to
watch over scp-049 reported that they
had heard clucking noises coming through
the speakers in the observation room now
assigned to watch and report on
scp-049's progress Dr omell watched the
plague doctor from the observation room
connected to the cameras and audio
recording devices in the creature's cell
ever since the bizarre and unanticipated
birth omel had been given the task of
compiling an extensive report on
everything that took place within the
cell for the most part everything seemed
fine or as fine as something so unusual
could seem the egg was in a healthy
condition nonetheless although the whole
event had the foundation doctor
wondering
scp-049 had always had a somewhat
bird-like appearance helped in no small
part by that Infamous beak-shaped mask
did the fact that this creature could
apparently lay eggs mean that the plague
doctor was some form of humanoid bird an
avian human hybrid that only mimicked
the plague doctors of old or had those
medieval Physicians created their masks
to emulate
scp-049 which had come first the plague
doctors or the plague doctor a debate as
confusing and cyclical as the one about
the chicken or the egg and now the
plague doctor also had an egg I don't
know about you but I'm starting to get a
headache just thinking about it
scp-049 had begun to softly Peck at the
surface of the egg when Dr omell decided
to step in and look for some answers to
his burning questions over the speakers
in 049 cell he asked for an explanation
the plague doctor answered that he was
checking his egg for signs of life
within its shell as if that answer
should have been obvious and he had
succeeded there was definitely something
living inside as the plague doctor
returned to sitting Atop The Egg omel
asked outright if scp-049 was in fact a
bird it was uncommon if not downright
unheard of for a humanoid anomaly to lay
eggs like this after a moment's thought
scp-049 replied with no as far as I'm
aware I have never been a bird yet
producing eggs is natural to me he
explained that while this had happened
before it had been at least a few
decades since the last time then the
plague doctor went back to sitting on
his egg humming as it rocked back and
forth in the nest ten days passed after
the egg had first arrived and now
scp-049 cell was brimming with activity
Foundation Personnel had fitted the room
with a glass screen to protect them from
the plague doctor with researchers
piling in into the safe side carrying
cameras and hurriedly taking notes
protected by a number of guards the big
day had seemingly arrived whatever had
been brimming and Brewing inside the egg
was about to hatch as the researchers
all whispered to each other with
excitement and Intrigue
scp-049 stood protectively on the other
side of the room just waiting in
fascinated expectation the pearlescent
egg started to shake Suddenly It's pale
surface cracking the cracks spread from
the center of the egg forking across the
shell like a lightning bolt over a dark
cloudy Sky something underneath was
pushing through pressing outwards from
within the egg splitting it apart as it
had tapped and pecked its way to Freedom
a small white beak poked a hole through
the shell that surrounded it piercing
the egg at last the creature within this
spawn of the plague doctor began to tear
itself through the barrier that had kept
it safe from the outside world until it
was ready to take its first steps with
both arms the thing tore itself out of
the egg all under the watch of the
foundation's doctors and researchers who
were stunned to see another plague
doctor emerging from the egg it was
small much smaller than the father that
had birthed it and cared for it while it
was waiting to hatch but it was
nonetheless a perfect miniature version
of scp-049 complete with the same kind
of robes the same beaked mask even with
a little hat on top of its head with a
gasp of pure excitement the original
plague doctor lifted up his new Mini
self and hugged the child in his arms
the excitement that had filled the room
up now quickly dissipated as the
audience of foundation Personnel quickly
realized that they had just witnessed
the live birth of a brand new anomaly of
which they understood virtually nothing
as Dr omell stepped forward to
cautiously ask scp-049 to put down its
Offspring the smaller plague doctor
smacked omel's hand with a stick before
leaping from its father's arms and
dashing out of the cell as alarms began
to blare indicating a breaching
containment
scp-049 wiped a tear from his eyes
stating he is the cure the new smaller
plague doctor now designated as
scp-049-j seems to have a talent for
evading capture by the foundation and
for frequently escaping containment
unlike its predecessor
scp-049 this Offspring has a body
beneath its robes that is composed
mostly of moss swans of tissue and
smaller plague doctor masks during the
occasions in which it has been
successfully detained by the foundation
scp-049-j has claimed that it is in fact
a powerful magical Doctrine wizard with
the ability to cure all that ails
mankind however to date it has been
unable to cure anything usually making
medical conditions actively worse when
you reach a certain level of wealth you
start to feel like nothing can touch you
you sped sunshine and crap gold at least
that's been my experience can't imagine
any of you can relate but please allow
me to explain how it feels when there's
three commas in your bank balance I know
time is money but don't worry I'm good
for it or at least I thought I was
before that night point is the more
money you get the higher you climb that
Golden Ladder the stronger the feeling
of security gets money can't buy
happiness or so the saying goes but
trust me when I say that it can buy
everything else and that's pretty close
that's right I'm one of the dreaded one
person
a straight up billionaire baby don't get
me wrong I'm not some guy who was born
with a silver spoon in my mouth I worked
hard I was lucky of course and I had
some help from my parents but who didn't
get a Little Help from their families
while growing up after my dad helped me
get into an Ivy League school and gave
me a 20 million dollar loan as a
graduation present I was completely on
my own I scraped and I saved and I
turned that loan into the biggest Tech
conglomerate in the entire world after I
made my first hundred million I stopped
worrying about being successful enough
driven enough good enough after my first
billion I felt like I could do anything
and honestly I could the money stopped
feeling real stop being anything except
a number ticking ever upward and
signifying that I would never run out of
points in The Game of Life I'd won I
purchased myself a rocket with a velvet
interior for luxury space travel I felt
a room in my house with vintage guitars
that had all previously been touched by
members of The Beatles just because I
could I moved into a cottage in Tuscany
a house in Martha's Vineyard a beach
house in Hawaii my Los Angeles mansion
and my my favorite a villa in the south
of France that's not all of them of
course but those are my top five if you
ever get the chance to have a house on
every continent I highly recommend it
just kidding I know most people won't
get the chance but maybe if you're lucky
you'll get an invitation to one of my
legendary parties if you're luckier than
lucky you'll find yourself with an
invitation to my annual costume party it
is an incredible spectacle every year
and this year was no exception picture
it me my beautiful wife an international
supermodel thank you very much and a few
hundred of our closest friends gathered
at my house nestled right up against the
French Riviera the theme was masquerade
ball and the dress code was strict no
one would be admitted without a mask or
a tire elegant enough for the party
inside what greeted them was nothing
short of absolute opulence I instructed
my party planner to spare no expense the
ballroom was outfitted with a massive
Swarovski chandelier thousands of
candles lighting the room Flames
sparkling in the Crystal and filling the
room with warm light in the corner a
string quartet borrowed from the
national Opera of Paris played next to
one of the six count them six champagne
fountains I commissioned a portrait of
me and my wife dressed to the nines and
wearing our masks and hung it in the
entryway to greet my guests and the
dining room guests could sit down to a
feast fit for Louis XIV complete with 30
courses including pheasant Pate poached
pears whole roasted boar and other
dishes inspired by the Palace of
Versailles for partygoers with more
modern palettes the Molecular Gastronomy
room was open with a chef on site to
serve flavored Foams and vaporized
cocktails or those who wanted to stick
to the ballroom could enjoy the past
around hors d'oeuvres but really why
choose if they wanted they could have a
bit of everything or a lot of it money
was truly No Object the party was going
great I was wearing my favorite suit
which cost more than most people spend
on a house and a custom designed mask
made from hundreds of black and white
diamonds with a few red diamonds thrown
in for a pop of color and because
they're the rarest variety of diamond in
the world the more you know right my
guests had all arrived and guards were
stationed at all entrances to make sure
no party crashers try to make their way
inside and take advantage of my
hospitality and generosity so imagine my
surprise when long after the guest list
had been completely checked off a
mysterious figure swept in and
interrupted everything my wife elbowed
me in the side as I was helping myself
to some Beluga caviar who is that she
hissed to me tilting her head towards
the doorway at the other end of the
ballroom I turned expecting to see a
foreign dignitary or an oil Baron she
had forgotten the name of but instead I
saw something much more bizarre there
standing like a shadow in the room full
of silk and gold was a person dressed in
thick black robes they were wearing a
mask but it was unsettling to look at
intense dark eyes peered out of the pale
ceramic that tapered into a long pointed
beak I dimly remember drawings of
medieval doctors wearing masks like
those as the Black Plague decimated
Europe This was just some edgy Party
Crasher looking for attention I knew
that but looking at them a chill ran up
my spy how did he get in I shook my head
motioning to one of the security guards
stationed near the entrance do your job
fellas come on rob my beefiest guard got
the signal and approached the Crasher I
took a sip of my drink eager to watch
this wannabe cool guy get booted from my
world he watched Rob come closer as he
stood completely still little black eyes
unblinking what was this guy's deal he
reached out one black loved hand and
touched Rob's throat with one finger as
soon as the stranger touched his skin
Rob dropped to the ground unmoving he
was all the way on the other side of the
room but somehow I just knew he was dead
as soon as Rob fell the party came to a
screeching halt my wife screamed and
tugged on my arm but I couldn't take a
step I just watched Frozen in place as
the stranger in the plague doctor mask
pulled a syringe from a pocket in his
robes and injected something thick and
black into Rob's corpse would just has
been a mound of dead flesh began to
thrash around hands grasping at nothing
legs kicking and something that looked
like Rob but was definitely not him
climbed to its feet it had his face his
body but its eyes were Hollow and dead
there was no light behind them they were
just flat the thing that once was raw
began to shuffle into the room the
stranger trailing behind it as he walked
he touched guests with his gloved hands
like Rob they dropped to the ground dead
at a single touch Gus began to scatter
in every direction running for their
lives still I couldn't get myself to
move a dozen people were dead on the
floor then two dozen then three as he
walked the stranger injected them with
more of the strange liquid and the dead
guests shambled to their feet or dragged
themselves along the floor with stiff
pale fingers the shuffling corpses that
were once my friends grabbed guests near
them with inhuman strength as they tried
to run away dragging them toward the
horrible doctor so he could kill and
transform them too I I had to make a
break for it I had to get out of there
but my legs wouldn't listen to me fear
and morbid curiosity froze me to the
spot there had to be at least 50 Zombies
by now and the doctor just kept going it
was getting closer and closer to me hand
outstretched and ready to deliver its
deadly touch I unstuck my tongue from
the roof of my mouth swallowed and spoke
why are you doing this the doctor paused
tilting his head to the side and thought
this home is overrun with the pestilence
it is my duty to contain its spread and
treat the infected he spoke formally in
a voice that reverberated from inside
the mask with a metallic Edge they must
be cured I had to think fast I could
talk my way out of this I've sold
companies made mergers avoided paying
taxes my whole life now I just had to
negotiate for my own life my friends
might be gone but I at least could save
myself you're you're a doctor I said he
seemed pleased at this I am a physician
yes he said you're trying to help I
continued yes I see you two are a man of
science he had stopped coming closer the
zombies had stopped advancing on me it
was working I don't know if you're aware
of this but I am a very wealthy man
doctor I took a drink of my champagne
doing my best to appear casual friendly
even I'm sure you're in need of funding
for your mission perhaps we could work
together you wish to Aid me in my
mission the doctor asked I do I lied I'm
in great health as you can see but I
don't want a
pestilence spreading around and
infecting me or my loved ones I'd like
to help you I pause searching for the
right words I could be your Patron the
doctor clapped his gloved hands together
and I could have sworn he smiled beneath
his beaked Visage
excellent this is the most fortuitous
meeting indeed I am glad to have found
you here sir if you would come with me
we may begin our work he turned and
swept out of the room gesturing for me
to follow I looked around for an exit
route a way to make a break for it but
there were too many corpses ready to
grab me within human strength and drag
me to certain death the room was filled
with them shuffling about in their torn
Formal Wear slack and Jaws hanging loose
and Hollow eyes watching me I had no
choice but to follow this guy and just
wait for my opportunity to get away I
don't know how long we walked down the
narrow Town streets in the dark every
time we passed an alley I thought I
could duck down the doctor got closer to
me with his deadly hands or a group of
zombies encircled me I was outside I
should have been home free but there was
nowhere to run eventually the doctor
stopped in front of an abandoned
dilapidated house the paint was peeling
off the walls and there was a hole that
rotted through the ceiling welcome sir
to my laboratory he made a grand
sweeping gesture inviting me to walk
through the door I obeyed crossing the
threshold the smell of Rod and dried
blood hit me so hard that I thought I
might throw up the house was dark I had
to squint to sea but I could make out
scattered piles of body parts animal and
human there was a table covered with
surgical equipment and next to it a
black leather doctor's bag there were
people in here too or they used to be
people they were silent zombies like the
others some stood along the walls at
silent attention others were lying on
the ground hooked up to IVs full of
strange liquid or strapped to gurneys
ready to be operated on
this this looks great my voice shook but
I hoped he wouldn't notice with my funds
we can upgrade your lab get you to a
more high-tech facility better lighting
more space research assistance actually
together we will eradicate the
pestilence once and for all there the
doctor pointed at the medical table to
my right grab a pair of gloves and slide
them on the doctor nodded as I squeezed
my hands into a pair of rubber medical
gloves absolutely can you show me more
of what you're working on good thinking
when his back was turned I would run out
the door and get to safety the doctor
approached the table covered with tools
and bent to pick up a scalpel now was my
moment I ran toward the door as fast as
my legs would carry me I collided with
something hard and cold it was robbed my
old bodyguard doing what he did best
keeping the perimeter secure sir where
are you going the doctor called are you
trying to abandon our work he paused for
a moment realizing what I had done did
you you deceive me his voice turned cold
angry no no I I couldn't come up with a
lie Rob wrapped his arms around my chest
holding me in place as the doctor
approached me with the scalpel in hand
you are not looking well my friend
perhaps you have fallen ill such a shame
I'd look forward to our collaboration he
drew the scalpel stretching his hand out
towards my neck I thrashed around arms
flailing and grabbing at his mask with
gloved hands what did this monster look
like underneath who was he what was he
the mask did not budge and I realized
this was no mask it was his face don't
worry his blade sliced into the side of
my neck I will make you well again his
pitch black eyes twinkled as he set to
work then everything went dark glass
shatters a d-class screams the show Cry
of an alarm sounds there's been a
contain reach of the SCP Foundation
somehow the plague doctor has escaped
his cell and is making a break for It
Against All Odds he finds the exit and
he's out he's free he's on the lamb but
how long can he elude the foundation's
attempts to track him down and recontain
him at any cost it will take all of his
cunning his intellect and his strange
anomalous abilities but he's going to
try and hold on to his Newfound Freedom
as tightly as he can I'm getting ahead
of myself here though let's start at the
beginning day one
scp-049 or the plague doctor may be an
esoteric anomaly whose grasp of medicine
is practically medieval but he's still a
doctor he didn't get this far by not
paying attention to his surroundings so
when an unexpected power outage
triggered by an experiment gone wrong
somewhere in the bowels of sight 19 gave
him the chance to escape captivity wow
he took it the foundation had recently
revoked his access to live experimental
subjects again and he had had enough it
was time to seize the moment and make a
Mad Dash for Freedom with the security
system down the doctor broke open the
door to his cell grabbed his trusty
Apothecary bag and ran into the Hall
guards were already swarming ready to
drag him back into captivity but he had
planned ahead swiftly he Uncorked a
glass bottle of silvery liquid spilling
it onto the floor where it began to eat
away at the tile the shoes of the guards
and if they maintain contact for too
long the soles of their feet this bought
him just enough time to keep running the
sounds of screaming down another Hall
and the raucous laughter of one Dr Jack
Bright signaled to the doctor that most
of the foundation staff were otherwise
occupied with this in mind he sprinted
on letting his kite in his body carry
him to the exit then for the first time
in far too long fresh air on his beak
the sun in his eyes the of cut grass and
damp leaves from the last night's Reign
the world was here waiting for him just
as he had left it of course the world
was still very much in danger he hadn't
just broken free for himself but to
address the pestilence head on as best
as he could but for now as he heard the
sound of the alarm the guards gaining on
him he had to prioritize his own safety
first he had to hide day two he ran for
ages he couldn't be quite sure how long
as he had no way to measure the passage
of time except the position of the sun
in the sky it set it Rose bathing the
countryside in soft yellow light and
said again plunging the land Into
Darkness all while he continued to run
then finally the plague doctor stopped
he had found a farm there was a little
Farmhouse but he did not dare disturb
the sleeping family and alarmed them
instead he turned to the barn for
shelter he let himself in to tiptoed
past the horses as they slept there and
made himself a bed from straw and a
burlap sack from his bag he pulled the
pillow and a little spray bottle he
misted the pillow with a lavender
scented oil and finally allowed himself
a moment to rest he did not need to
sleep like ordinary men but after such a
long journey he could get pretty close
day three the morning of the plague
doctor's third day of Freedom began with
a high-pitched Winnie of a terrified
horse and the Frantic stamping of hooves
the doctor opened his eyes to the site
of one of the horses now awake and not
at all happy to see a stranger in its
Barn making its fear and displeasure
known Buttercup a man called from
outside the barn that you girl what's
got you spooked the door to the barn
creaked open and before the doctor could
do anything he was face to face with the
farmer who owned the land who are you
what are you doing in my barn the man
demanded good sir I apologize for the
intrusion I am but a humble traveler
seeking shelter you need to get out of
here and stop scaring my horses now
don't make me come back with my Shaka no
need for that sort of thing I I will be
on my way the doctor collected his
things and decided to spare the old
farmer rather than use more extreme
methods to change his mind he left the
barn in a hurry day four day four with a
farm far behind him the plague doctor
trudged Along on his journey always
keeping an eye out for unmarked Vans and
armed guards so far though he was safe
he hadn't had a spare moment to return
to his experiments though which was
beginning to wear on him the work was
what had motivated him to break out in
the first place and now he wasn't sure
when he would be able to make time for
it cruel irony indeed but then as if his
silent prayer had been answered he heard
A peculiar sound coming from the woods
just off the dirt road he was walking
down a sickly Bray from an injured
animal a poor soul in need a patient he
followed the sound to its source a deer
lay on its side clearly sick or injured
somehow do not be afraid my friend the
doctor said softly you are sick but I
can make you well he satis bag down on
the grass and got to work first he
touched the deer with a gloved hand
stopping its heart and putting it out of
its misery then he reached into his bag
for his trusty tools and some of his
best medicines in no time at all the
deer was reanimated cured walking around
again like new sure it was a little bit
different stumbling a bit and each eye
looking in a different direction but the
doctor considered the treatment a
success a day well spent day five the
next day feeling reinvigorated after his
successful encounter with the deer the
plague doctor began his quest for
shelter Anew he walked for most of the
day until as the sun was setting He Came
Upon something curious a house
dilapidated looking with a large sign
out front reading House of Horrors enter
if you dare though he didn't know it the
doctor had stumbled upon that local
Town's Premier seasonal haunted house
attraction to him it was simply an empty
house he could take up residence inside
he was curious and a bit perplexed as he
walked past plastic skeletons
animatronic werewolves that popped out
from behind styrofoam tombstones and
giant fake spiders and cotton cobwebs
none of the fake monsters gave him
trouble so though he was confused by
what he saw he continued to explore the
house then he found something incredible
a laboratory there was a long stainless
steel table with a mannequin strapped to
it a row of prop surgical tools sat on a
train next to the mannequin and along
the back shelf were rows and rows of
jars filled with liquids that looked
like something the plague doctor himself
would pull out of his bag he couldn't
believe his eyes after wandering
aimlessly for days he found the perfect
place almost as if it had been made just
for him of course it wasn't it was for
the paying customers who would be coming
to the haunted house the next day along
with the actors hired to perform inside
but he didn't need to know any of that
yet he replaced the jars with his own
and the tools with functioning ones with
the exception of the plastic body on the
table which he privately wished was a
real human subject this was absolutely
perfect day six The Haunt actor showed
up for work and were surprised to find a
new guy had beat the mayor and he was
already in costume they Shrugged it off
they were making minimum wage and that
wasn't enough to ask any questions they
were there to suit up and get spooky and
that was it they did appreciate his
plague doctor costume though it was much
higher budget than anything they had did
you make that get up yourself asked a
friendly zombie indeed I did the doctor
replied cheerfully happy to finally
counter a group of individuals who are
unafraid of him nice bro the zombie gave
him a thumbs up and if the plague doctor
could with his rigid beaked face he
would have smiled these new colleagues
were a bit unusual looking with their
ghostly white faces vampire fangs green
tinge makeup and excess fur but their
kindness was encouraging meanwhile The
Haunt actors were gossiping amongst
themselves wondering where the new
plague doctor character came from who
approved it who hired this guy why was
he doing that accent whatever he was
whatever he was plenty scary and nice
enough guy to get to work with so
Frankenstein's monster let the plague
doctor have the laboratory set and moved
himself into the graveyard the customers
loved him too shrieking with delight as
he welcomed them into his laboratory
asking if any of them would like to
volunteer to be a test subject lucky for
them they had already been warned not to
touch any of the actors while walking
through the attraction as his first
night at his unintentional job to a
close the plague Doctor's new friends
bit him farewell we're gonna go to a bar
up the road for a couple drinks the
ghostly bride said wanna come ah no time
for revelry the plague doctor replied I
must attend to my work take care the
woman just laughed okay see you later
and so the plague doctor spent his night
in the haunted house again tinkering
with his tools and his tissue samples
listening to the royalty-free scary
music tape play again and again on
repeat into the night day seven the next
day attendance at the haunted house was
slow the actors with little to do spent
their time scrolling aimlessly on their
phones filming joke videos for social
media and pranking each other one of
them got the bright idea to pull a prank
on the new hire the stranger that none
of them knew much about he would have a
friend turn out the lights in the
laboratory and when the lights were
turned back on he would have replaced
the mannequin on the table he couldn't
have known what would happen all he
wanted to do was startle the new guy
free cam out with the site of an
unexpected werewolf on his operating
table and it was effective sort of the
plague doctor Frozen plays When the
Lights Went Out calling hello what is
happening and when the room was
illuminated once more he took in the
sight of the living being on the
operating table my friend who've come to
me for treatment the werewolf started to
get up disappointed he hadn't managed to
elicit a scream but the plague doctor
reached out a hand to stop him and that
was curtains for that particular actor
as soon as the plague doctor's gloved
hand made contact with the man in the
werewolf costume his heart stopped oh
dear the plague doctor remarked do not
fear I have the Cure you'll be all right
in no time at all by the time the rest
of the actors came to see what had
happened to the werewolf there was a
real zombie in the haunted house then it
was pure chaos actors running and
screaming knocking over props and
abandoning their seasonal gig darting
between customers as they went shrieking
don't go in there it's real naturally
this only made them want to check it out
even more but by the time they got
inside there was no sign of the plague
doctor only one very lost zombie in a
werewolf costume a few jars broken and
all the chaos and Footsteps in the
drying grass outside leaving town days 8
to 18. the plank doctor spent all of his
eighth day on the Run walking once more
it was starting to get used to this the
endless drudgery of the path to Freedom
he hated to admit it but he was almost
starting to miss his cell back at the
foundation the routine of it the quiet
time to work the three meals given to
him each day even though he didn't need
to eat to survive he missed food and
drink The Simple Pleasures of bread meat
cheese fruit a mug of tea a cup of wine
he sighed to himself wistfully then he
caught a whiff of something lovely he
lifted his beak taking in another deep
breath the unmistakable scent of roast
pheasant hearty and warm beneath it
something else mulled wine spiced and
inviting smells that reminded him of
home of days long lost he couldn't be
certain where it would lead or if there
would be a seat for him at the table but
he couldn't resist following the
Heavenly Aroma to its source as he drew
closer to the smell of food and
merriment he could hear music the
plucking of a liar the high Trill of a
flute singing and clapping then he
finally spotted it rows of colorful
tents long banquet tables minstrels
wandering about and playing ballads to
anyone who would listen men women and
children frolicking in elaborate
costumes plate armor robes gowns and
more though the plague doctor didn't
know how to describe what he was seeing
he had wandered onto the sight of one of
the state's largest Renaissance Fairs it
just so happened to be opening day and
he was just in time for the celebratory
Feast good day doctor a nobleman tipped
his hat to scp-049 are you speaking to
me the plague doctor was taken aback by
the recognition why of course you're the
only doctor I see her majesty the queen
thanks you for your service for keeping
us all safe from the Great Plague the
plane doctor had no idea that this man
was an actor playing along with him in
what he assumed was a scene for the
tourists instead he took the words to
Heart swelling with pride and gratitude
for the recognition good sir it is my
duty and my honor the plague doctor
nodded politely luckily for him an
unbeknownst to the rest of the cast of
players at the fair the man originally
hired to play the town plague doctor had
booked a commercial role that morning
and decided not to go into work the
man's choice not to call and let anyone
know the rude led to a fortuitous
misunderstanding for scp-049 please join
us at the Royal table the nobleman made
a sweeping gesture with his arm inviting
the doctor to sit and dine with him and
the rest of the actors playing members
of the Court thank you for your kindness
if he could the plague doctor would have
smiled he dying to his heart's contempt
that afternoon listening to sounds of
music and laughter he slotted into his
role at the fair even better than his
position at the haunted house he
answered questions from tourists about
his work as a physician warned them of
the dangers of the great pestilence and
posed for the occasional photograph he
spent a wonderful 10 days living in a
stylized artificial version of the past
basking in the warm glow of camaraderie
though the other actors wondered why he
never took his mask off even to eat then
sadly it was time for the fair to pack
up for the season the plague doctor bid
his new friends farewell and to climb
their offers to exchange numbers and
keep in touch he would however always
remember them fondly days 19-41 as he
was departing the fairgrounds the doctor
caught a glimpse of strange men
approaching some of the actors showing
Federal Badges and asking them questions
he couldn't be certain that it was the
foundation but it was more than enough
to make him cautious he would have to
retreat into the woods once more and
stay out of sight he laid low for quite
some time for 22 days to be exact but
then on day 41 day 41-52 it started to
snow white blanketed the forest floor
soft and cold the weather wouldn't kill
him of course but it was uncomfortable
he would need to find some more
efficient shelter to escape from the
elements before the winter storm
worsened he trudged through the snow
into a new town small and quaint there
was an abandoned church at the edge of
the main road a bit broken down but the
roof held firm against the onslaught of
ice and wind so the plague doctor made
it his new home for the next 12 days
working quietly and staying out of sight
day 53-57 on the eve of the plague
doctor's 53rd day on the run from the
SCP Foundation he was stirred from his
work by the sound of a choir of
beautiful voices outside he looked to
find a group of Christmas carolers
singing together the rows of houses
along the streets covered in colorful
lights and glittering decorations
wanting to get a little closer to the
music the doctor left his hiding spot
for the first time in nearly two weeks
but as the choir saw strangely shaped
Dark Shadow emerging from the abandoned
church they screamed and Scattered in
every direction one of them yelled
something about the Krampus as they went
frightened by the whole interaction as
cp049 found himself a new spot under a
bridge it was cold but isolated at least
it was for five days day 58 on day 58 a
group of local teenagers Rowdy and
looking to make some trouble spotted the
plague doctor squatting under the bridge
they pelted him with snowballs laughing
before he could do anything about it
fortunately for the teens they then ran
back to their car and sped away drenched
in ice in cold water miserable and
irritated the plague doctor searched for
another place to stay day 59 to day 4.
the plague doctor was able to slip into
another relatively quiet building the
local Community Theater which happened
to be an old opera house repurposed as
the site of volunteer-run musicals while
the town's folk began rehearsals for the
production of the Phantom of the Opera
the plague doctor watched from above
hiding in the shadows every so often the
stagehand would catch a glimpse of a
cape the silhouette of a face a pair of
dark eyes but no one believed her when
she tried to tell them that the Phantom
was real at least until a handyman went
up into the rafters to install some
lights and saw the plague doctor for
himself then it was time for him to flee
to a new town day 85 to day 89 on day 85
the plague doctor climbed up onto the
roof of a dark house to avoid a
particularly aggressive dog and let
himself in through the Attic Window the
next morning a little girl came up into
the attic in search of a lost toy and
found him there he waited for her to
scream but she didn't she introduced
yourself as Abby and asked if you would
like some cookies and milk he accepted
her gracious offer and the two visited
with each other for several days until
Abby's parents asked who she was talking
to they didn't take it well when she
answered the Birdman in the Attic day
90. on day 90 Abby's parents called the
police who had been warned to look out
for a man in a bird mask and got in
touch with her contacts at the SCP
Foundation feeling the authorities
closing in as cp049 took to the
Wilderness once more day 91 to day 99
though the air was still painfully cold
the plague doctor managed to set up camp
using tools from his bag to build a fire
and construct a makeshift tent he stayed
there for three days before intending to
move on and throw the foundation off of
his Trail but he was slowed by the
appearance of a group of hikers bundled
up against the winter weather and
exploring the woods afraid he couldn't
trust them the doctor touched one to
convince him to leave the man fell to
the ground dead and as his companions
were ran away screaming the doctor vowed
to cure him working against the
inopportune conditions it took him five
more days to reanimate the hiker on day
100 of his time on the lamb the
foundation finally closed in the plague
doctor was just stitching up a large
incision in his patient's chest when he
heard the click of a gun behind him come
with us peacefully and we won't have to
sedate you the officer said with a heavy
side the plague doctor held up his hands
stepping back from his patient just as
its Undead body sat up blinking its
unseeing eyes very well I will go back
to tell you the truth gentlemen this has
all been a bit too much trouble I could
use the rest there are many Mysteries
locked within the walls of the SCP
Foundation from potentially world-ending
scenarios to the minds of monsters like
the hard to destroy reptile day after
day the research staff worked tirelessly
to unravel these secrets contain them
and when necessary term
but what about another researcher
another man of science trying
desperately to uncover the truth today
we'll put down the clipboards and white
lab coats in favor of black robes a
beaked mask or rather skull and a
seemingly endless doctor's bag to take a
look at the average day for one peculiar
physician
scp-049 the plague doctor we took the
liberty of turning the researcher into
the research subject watching scp-049 as
he went about his daily life from his
inscruciable experiments to his strange
habits it was difficult to Chronicle
without tipping the good doctor off as
to what we were up to but we were able
to get everything we needed to make the
video you're watching right now Welcome
Friends enemies and future patience to a
day in the life of
scp-049 6 am the great dying never
sleeps and neither really does the
plague doctor unlike ordinary human
doctors he does not need to get his
eight hours of shut eye in order to
function properly the sharp mind of
scp-049 never dulls no matter how long
he is awake of course he does
occasionally lie down in his containment
cell arms crossed over his chest like a
mummy breathing at a noticeably slower
pace for several hours however he does
not appear to actually enter a REM cycle
nor does his behavior change when he is
denied this rest time it would appear he
is simply for a lack of a better term
brainstorming for a little while before
getting up to start the new day back
when he lived on the outside he would
rise to the sound of a rooster's Crow or
the ringing of church bells in the Town
Square but now we discovered the plague
doctor becomes active for the day at
exactly 6 am on the dot we're not sure
how he manages such Precision since
there are no clocks visible from his
room but then again there's a lot we
still don't understand about him but
whether you wake to the sound of a
buzzing phone alarm or your own perfect
tuned internal clock there's nothing
wrong with getting a nice early start on
your day's tasks just like he doesn't
need sleep the plank doctor does not
rely on steady caloric intake for his
energy instead he is sustained by the
satisfaction of doing what needs to be
done but that doesn't mean he can't eat
he enjoys starting the day with
breakfast often consisting of toasted
bread with butter jam or honey if he's
feeling particularly indulgent sometimes
all three and he washes it down with an
espresso or cup of steaming hot lavender
tea though he's a serious man he
understands the importance of treating
yourself first thing in the morning it
sets the tone for the day and gives him
the Boost he'll need for what's to come
8 AM some people enjoy a long language
morning routine they shower they do
their 11-step skin care regimen they do
some gentle stretching to wake up their
muscles and circular system
scp-049 is not one of those people he is
a no must fuss type through and through
besides with gloves robes and a mask
that are parts of his physical body it
is uncertain if he has any skin that
needs caring for or produces sweat that
might need to be washed away we're not
sure if you can use Korean sheet masks
on kaitin but we really don't think that
the plague doctor would let us try with
no hygiene to worry about it's time for
scp-049 to get going on his favorite
activity the one that borders on all
encompassing Obsession working towards a
cure for the great dying the pestilence
that he has devoted his existence to
fighting Once Upon a Time the foundation
was so kind as to offer him corpses to
experiment on but given the doctor's
pension for resurrecting the dead and
turning them into mindless zombies that
follow his every command they decided to
do away with that particular program You
Can't Always Get What You Want
especially when what you want results in
an army of the undead living test
subjects won't work either be because
his deadly touch and his tendency toward
shall we say unconventional surgical
methods it's just not the best idea so
what's a doc to do his best with what
he's got of course around this time of
mourning he sets up a neat row of tools
and implements on his favorite workbench
and selects various tissue samples to
dissect to inject with Solutions and
dissolve in jars to study from every
angle he can until he finally cracks the
cure to the pestilence 10 AM the work
may be his top priority but no man is an
island even a man who isn't quite human
needs to engage in polite conversation
we do still live in a society after all
after working in silence for a couple of
hours the plank doctor has gotten into
the habit of talking to whoever happens
to be passing by his containment
facility sometimes it's a custodian
mopping up blood stains sometimes it's a
doctor he can engage with about their
mutual love of science and research
sometimes it's another SCP one of the
few lucky permitted to roam about the
facility without much supervision today
it was scp-507 The Reluctant Dimension
Hopper back from his latest involuntary
travel to another world he was wearing a
pair of cargo shorts and a t-shirt
emblazoned with a variety of comic book
characters he approached the window of
scp-049's containment cell with a
cheerful wave hey Doc how's it going you
smiled ah hello
the doctor's eye is shown excitedly from
the depths of his mask how nice it is to
see you I'm having a most productive day
and you all how did you fare on your
Voyage you're looking well I presume it
was successful the plague doctor wasn't
exactly sure what this friendly man got
up to when he was away from the
foundation perhaps he was a merchant or
a cartographer charting foreign lands
one of the white-coated scientists had
attempted to explain it to him but was
called Away by more important Affairs
before he could have his questions
answered
scp-507 shuddered at the question not my
favorite his face paled at the memory I
don't want to get into it too much but
I'll just say this spiders lots and lots
of spiders I'm quite sorry to hear that
may your next destination be a better
one
scp-507's frown dissolved into a grin at
the doctor's words appreciate it DOC
well we'll see I guess I'm gonna go ask
God some questions about what happens
when we die good luck with the science
stuff you pray pressed a palm to the
glass inviting the plague doctor to give
him a high five through the window
haltingly a bit confused about the
gesture the doctor pressed his hand to
the glass in return see you around
indeed the doctor waved as the friendly
blonde man headed off to explore his own
mortality and probably make a smoothie
12 p.m right at noon the doctor pauses
his work to enjoy a nice lunch like all
of his meals his food is delivered
through a slot in the door his lunch
consists mostly often of a wedge of hard
cheese a small bunch of grapes and some
Goose liver pate with crackers
frequently he will ask to join the staff
and other freely moving anomalies in the
cafeteria but due to safety concerns he
is not permitted to do so the last thing
we need is him brushing hands with
someone while reaching for an extra
scoop of mashed potatoes and them
dropping dead right there on the tile
floor still it is lonely for him to eat
in there watching the rest of the staff
walk to lunch gabbing about their
weekends and discussing what the soup of
the day might be all on this day the
plague doctor was having an especially
frustrating lunch as he nibbled
delicately on his cheese he heard a
twinkling melody in the distance very
very faint coming from somewhere outside
suddenly there was a flurry of activity
in the hall as Foundation employees made
their way towards the source the music
excuse me he called to a passing
security guard what is all the commotion
about Dr Wright stole an ice cream truck
free ice cream for everyone the
marvelous what a treat might I request
you procure a cup for me too but before
he could finish his question she was
already gone yelling don't take all the
strawberry before I get there
scp-049 watched beak pressed against the
glass as a parade of people walked past
carrying cones ice cream bars bowls
piled high with ice cream Scoops hot
fudge nuts and cherries it seemed like
everyone was enjoying their ice cream
cooling down on a hot day with a sweet
treat except for him even some of the
other scps were getting in on the fun
scp-999 ooze by the door holding a
chocolate Vanilla swirl cone a sundae
and a chocolate covered frozen banana it
paused at the side of the doctor's sad
expression making an inquisitive
gurgling sound good afternoon dear
creature it seems I've been left out of
the festivities the plague doctor's side
the Tickle Monster gurgled again sliding
over to the slot in the door what are
you he trailed off as the slimy little
friend eased the slot open and pushed
the Sunday into plastic spoon inside the
Sunday spilled a little bit on its way
in but remained mostly intact thank you
I am ever in your debt the plague doctor
exclaimed the Tickle Monster was already
departing off to brighten someone else's
day no matter someone had remembered him
and for once he didn't mind being
prohibited from eating in the canteen
even from his cell he was still a part
of things 1 30 PM every so often the
plague doctor experiences a joyous break
in his routine he is given a test
subject not a human subject of course or
even a living subject but a fresh
organic specimen nonetheless as a reward
for good behavior and incentive to
continue cooperating with the foundation
staff
scp-049 is occasionally given a deceased
animal specimen to dissect and
experiment on in this particular case it
was a large adult cow that I'm told
passed away from natural causes after a
life of grazing happily in the Sun as
the cow's body was wheeled into his
containment cell by a group of
researchers claddin hazmat suits the
plague doctor clasped his gloved hands
together excitedly one of the
researchers leaned over to another and
whispered I thought this was for Sloppy
Joe day his colleague solemnly shook his
head all right here you go doctor
another piped up marvelous thank you
gentlemen thank you
scp-049 exclaimed he was so overcome
with delight that he patted one of the
researchers on the back the man tends
for a moment terrified at the sudden
physical contact but relaxed when he
remembered that his protective gear
protected him from the deadly effects of
a touch from the plague doctor yeah
you got it buddy the man let out a cyber
Leaf hard still racing are you feeling
quite alright my friend the doctor
cocked his head to the side watching the
man's face closely you seemed troubled
perhaps I should provide you with a
cursory examination I would hate to see
my benefactor fall ill I'm fine I I'm
just a little tired lots to do can't
stay gotta get to the next thing the man
laughed nervously come on let's go he
hissed to his colleagues rushing towards
the exit they followed never taking
their eyes off the plague doctor as they
went history will remember your
contribution to the advancement of
Medical Science the doctor said solemnly
waving goodbye to the men as they left
and resealed the door to the room 4pm
Eureka cried the plague doctor after a
moment its eyes opened and it let out a
warped strange mooing sound that echoed
down the Halls it stumbled to its feet
milky eyes rolling around in its head as
it took its first breath since it passed
away the cow had been brought back to
life but like all the patients the
doctor had successfully cured so far it
was not quite right it swelled and
bulged in strange places black slime
dribbled from its nostrils and mouth and
it shuffled around the small room
aimlessly waiting for guidance as it
locked eyes with a researcher walking
past looking at it through the glass it
let out another moo chomping its teeth
in anticipation of a bite like anyone
else briefed on the containment
procedures for scp-049 this man knew
that any resurrections were strictly off
limits for the anomaly no matter how
proud the plague doctor was of his
little project for the day he could not
be allowed to keep it it would be
confiscated and terminated he called for
his supervisor and soon a group of armed
guards were bursting through the door
tipping the Zombie Cow on her side of
the group of rural teens on a Rowdy
night out all the while the plague
doctor shouted at them how dare you on
the hamper immediately but the guards
did not listen they injected the cow
with enough tranquilizers to knock out a
herd of elephants and hauled it out of
the room towards the incinerator alone
in his room the plague doctor sat with
his head in his hands making the sound
of crying though no tears could be seen
running down his masked face we talked
about this doctor a senior researcher
spoke to him through the window you
can't have reanimated corpses in your
cell it's a security concern she was by
first breakthrough in months
with a sigh the senior researcher
pressed a button to Aid in calming the
distressed anomaly down a hissing sound
filled the containment cell as the scent
of fresh lavender was pumped into the
space the doctor lifted his head taking
a deep breath and slowly relaxing his
shoulders very well please do me one
favor my friend bring me her brain I can
do that the senior researcher nodded but
you can't do this again or will have to
revoke your test subject privileges
again my work is not a privilege it is a
calling a necessity the doctor pounded a
glove fist on the floor all right of
course let me get that brain for you 7pm
sometime mid evening the plague doctor's
meal slot opens again as his dinner is
pushed through for him to enjoy today's
supper is roasted potatoes and onions a
cut of baked fish more crusty bread and
a small cup of fragrant red wine on
special occasions he is even able to
request a second glass of wine to wash
down the Troubles of the day after the
cow incident this is not one of those
days so he drinks his one allotted cup
slowly savoring it along with his food
most culinary enthusiasts would suggest
against red wine with fish but the
plague doctor does not live by the rules
of man he makes his own 8 PM after his
dinner scp-049 begins tidying his
workspace preparing to wind down for the
night he wipes down his work table
clearing it of Blood Sweat and other
mysterious liquids he returns his
various tools to their home in his
doctor's bag sealing the lids on his
jars and placing them back inside he
works hard but one cannot work all the
time rest taking the time for deep
thought and processing all that he has
learned throughout the day is just as
vital 10 pm to end the day the plague
doctor engages in one of his few Simple
Pleasures he reads he has requested and
been provided various texts from the
foundation ranging from the medical to
the literary he has a compendium of the
writings of Hippocrates climbing the
elders texts of medicine and natural
science as well as some Modern
scientific texts he has largely
disregarded for lighter reading he has
set aside the Canterbury Tales Lady
Chatterley's Lover the Lover by
Marguerite
it seems that when it comes to his
fiction the plague doctor has a bit of a
romantic side he lies on his back
reading by the overhead light listening
as the sounds of the foundation quiet
down for the night the once bustling
facility now has only the occasional
footsteps the sounds of doors closing
and Machinery being powered down as
those who can go home to their lives on
the outside do but scp-049 is not one of
them he has always lived for the science
for the work and now he lives in a
research facility full-time it may not
be an ideal life but he has found a way
to make do with it and tomorrow he will
go up against his greatest enemy the
illness he has sworn to cure once again
and there you have it folks a day in the
life of the mysterious masked physician
is there anything from the plague
doctor's daily routine that you think
you might want to start incorporating
into your own day-to-day lives let us
know down in the comments sometimes no
matter how distant success may seem we
just have to keep working toward our
goals no one exemplifies that better
than the oh so determined scp-049 and
his tireless attempts to rid the world
of the pestilence once and for all sure
his methods aren't always the most
helpful but everybody makes mistakes the
most important thing is to try your best
welcome dear viewers to another tale of
excitement and Intrigue from The
Archives of the SCP Foundation today
we're covering A peculiar story titled
Foundation facilities and how to loot
them our story opens on shock a member
of
scp-4799 frantically running for her
life
scp-4799 in case you aren't already
aware is a group of Smugglers also known
by the name Mariachis Merchants now the
merchants aren't your average every day
under the table Traders mind you this
group is capable of trans Universal
travel stealing advanced technology from
other universes members of Mariachi's
Merchants will then sell these devices
to turn a profit each of these members
of which there are believed to be seven
originally come from a separate Universe
outside of our own and shock she's one
of the best blaster in her hand shock
ran down the corridor stopping at a
t-shaped intersection frantically trying
to decide which way to turn next the
energy weapon in her hand was still warm
to the touch she'd only just fired it
down to the last 12 shots 13. if she was
lucky there was only meant to be one
life form nearby the only other living
thing in a two kilometer radius but
chalk had quickly learned that she was
far from alone two things wearing lab
coats things that had perhaps once been
human beings were shambling their way
closer to her the nearest door was
locked protected by a keypad but there
was no time to hack her way inside let
letting out a growl shock turned an open
fire on her pursuers the pair of
creatures that hadn't registered as life
forms but were still inexplicably alive
energy bolts spat from her Blaster
disintegrating them both in an instant
turning her Focus to the nearby door
shock pushed a thin black device into a
key card slot connected to a thin screen
that controlled it she grumbled about
how what had seemed like a simple
Scavenging Mission had gone South so
quickly the planet appeared to be dead
at least from the perspective of the
Mariachi's merchant ship in orbit what
was the worst that could happen turns
out losing communication with a crew for
one they'd been radio silent after the
ship was reportedly fired upon the
merchants had promised to come back for
shock once they'd shaken off whoever was
shooting at them the facility she was
trying to scavenge had once belonged to
the SCP Foundation presumably a long
time ago codenamed site 101 built under
a spacecraft launch compound it should
have been a gold mine filled with all
sorts of valuable technology but so far
far it didn't seem like there was
anything left in the facility that
justified the dangerous trip the keypad
flashed green as the door unlocked Shaw
collected up her hacking device as the
door opened and one of the creatures
appeared on the other side reacting with
Incredible speed shock blasted the
creature into dust cursing at its body
as it disintegrated Adam by Adam what
were these things and why did the
merchant sensors not read them as life
forms she pushed the question to the
back of her mind there was a time and
place to contemplate what could be
classified as alive and this was neither
hurtling down the newly opened Corridor
shock headed towards an open office door
hiding as quietly as possible in the
office making sure the door was secure
enough that those Horrors outside
wouldn't follow her shock took a moment
to calm herself she sat herself down on
a leather chair in front of the dark
wood desk that filled most of the space
in the office it had belonged to one Dr
Dwyer according to the computer that
stood atop the desk which shocked began
to hack in to once again using her key
card cracking device after about a half
an hour working through some very
sophisticated security software she
eventually managed to force her way into
the computer and started clicking
through its files the first thing she
uncovered in a folder that was
conveniently labeled important was an
email from the o5 command to the
director of this abandoned former
Foundation site along with other
high-ranking members of personnel the
subject simply read farewell in the
email 05-7 mentioned that the last
number of Escape ships had successfully
launched from site 101 and arrived at
Colony stations it seemed that some kind
of war was imminent and would ravage the
entire Earth leaving nothing behind so
in their Infinite Wisdom the SCP
Foundation had been using its vast
resources to evacuate its Personnel off
world meanwhile the Personnel at site
101 would stamp their posts perhaps to
repopulate or rebuild the Earth after
the impending War had passed that email
had been sent in the year 2217 a whole
18 years before shock had arrived at
this facility hoping to rate it the next
email in the folder was headed with the
words Intruder sent just under a month
before a para Foundation security
Personnel officer Sanchez and meche had
happened across a breach in the
ventilation system according to their
reports it looked as if someone or
something had forced its way in with
some kind of metal Implement shortly
after a third officer officer Peterson
failed to respond to a radio check
seemingly going missing security had
been advised to travel in groups and
engage any unknown entity with lethal
Force something had made its way into
the facility and it had arrived just
before shock did uneasy still not sure
what had happened here the dimension
hopping scavenger read on the third and
final email entry had been sent the day
after the last this time security had a
better idea of what they were up against
surveillance footage from within the
facility had revealed the Intruder to be
none other than S
cp049 it had claimed the lives of
multiple security officers with two of
them confirmed to have been instances of
scp-049-2 being from a different
Universe however shock had no idea what
an scp-049 was nor did she like the idea
of being trapped with one now in case
you like shock haven't heard of the
infamous plague doctor then here's a
brief bit of context on
scp-049 a tall figure shrouded in Long
Black robes a hood over his head with
only a white beaked mask protruding from
underneath these aren't just parts of
his attire though the SCP Foundation
discovered that all of the pieces of
scp-049's outfit are part of his
physical body made out of muscle and
bone the blank doctor's primary goal is
to find those he deems to be infected
with something he refers to as the
pestilence if he ever senses this
Affliction he will attempt to make
direct skin contact with the person
carrying it
scp-049's touch is lethal killing anyone
who comes into contact with him in a
matter of minutes you might think that's
all the plague doctor does going from
person to person killing them by a touch
but you would be wrong once he has
killed the victim scp-049 then begins
performing a crude outdated form of
surgery on their corpse using equipment
he produces from his mysterious medical
bag he injects a number of unknown
chemicals into a person's carcass
eventually turning them into an instance
of
scp-049-2 in other words a zombie and
that's exactly what it had done to at
least two of the site 101 security
officers when shock delve further into
the computer examining some security
footage not only did she watch a
monstrosity in a shredded security
uniform shambling through a corridor but
there was something else following it a
figure completely clad in Black robes
its face shrouded behind an eerie beaked
mask shock decided her best course of
action was to find out as much as she
could about scp-049 then using the
facility's security cameras to figure
out the quickest route to find any
propulsion Tech that the foundation
might have left lying around she
familiarized herself with the
foundation's extensive file on scp-049
learning what the plague doctor could do
the part shock found to be particularly
unsettling was knowing that the entity
could shut down an organism's biological
functions whenever it made direct skin
contact best to try and avoid him she
told herself studying the camera feeds
shock noticed
scp-049-2s that had all been the former
staff of this facility they didn't seem
to move around much unless provoked all
she had to do was make it through the
corridors to a door labeled propulsion
testing without the dash twos noticing
her sounds easy in theory and it would
have been easier in practice if there
weren't currently eight of the zombies
standing in her path to the testing room
with a tight grip around her Blaster
shot bolted from the office barreling
full Sprint down the corridor she
already knew from watching the cameras
that the first the
scp-049-2s was around the nearest Corner
opening fire she went speeding past its
remains as it turned into little more
than a smoldering pile on the floor
around the next Corner were another two
of the creatures dispatched as quickly
as the first with a bright blue crackle
of the energy weapon so far so good but
shock was already anticipating seeing a
group of five
scp-049-2s huddled together the next
obstacle inner way sure enough she had
navigated her way through the facility's
hallways towards them making sure she
had the element of surprise on her side
she blasted the oncoming mob of zombies
screaming as they were struck by the
blue light of her Blaster only to vanish
vaporize forever all except for the
fifth and final
scp-049-2 instance shock had fired her
fifth shot too soon missing the last of
the creatures she waited for it to close
the distance between them hoping for a
closer Target but the monstrosity
knocked the gun from her hands shock
pulled a fusion bomb from her bag
wrapping the unstable energy cell in her
coat she let the creature grab the
makeshift bomb from her picking up her
weapon and running as the bomb detonated
exhausted she reached the propulsion
testing room injured after her fight
with the dash too shock had hoped her
troubles were over and for a moment they
certainly seemed to be she had stumbled
across a motherload of tech modified
reality anchors and all kinds of
equipment that would be perfect Salvage
but then from the Shadows something new
stepped forward the plague doctor
himself shock Drew her Blaster again and
pulled the trigger but the weapon was
spent sparking in her hands as it failed
to fire Frozen she stared at scp-049 and
it stared back lowering her weapon shock
tried to calmly introduce herself to the
looming cloaked anomaly I'm shocked nice
to meet you you're or rather these
people call you scp-49 right sure did a
bang-up job of carrying everyone in here
from the looks of things for a moment
they talked scp-049 had heard the
foundation Personnel at site 101 talking
of being the last men on Earth and made
its way into the facility to save them
as he put it ridding them of the
pestilence shock explained that the rest
of the planet's surface outside had been
severely irradiated and that there was
no one living up top anymore all while
sneakily sliding pieces of expensive
looking Tech into her bag
scp-049 argued that there were still
people left on Earth that site 42 housed
the very last remnants of humanity but
they had been Untouched by disease they
were pure but shock didn't care one bit
instead she made a move nobody would
have expected she offered the plague
doctor a lift the Mariachi's Merchants
would be coming back for her soon and
their ship was able to take them
anywhere in the Multiverse after
pondering for a moment
scp-049 asked to be taken with them to
find where the rest of the sick were
unwilling to accept his work was done as
long as you agree to keep your hands to
yourself shock told him as a gray orb
appeared in the room hovering above the
floor without touching the ceiling it
was time to leave now go check out
scp-049 the plague doctor captured and
scp-049 what actually is the pestilence
the plague doctor questions and theories
for more videos that definitely won't
give you the pestilence seriously we
promise